zubin damanya is an american physician
an assistant professor
a comedian and was the practicing
hospitalist at stanford university
school of medicine
for 10 years he also runs z-dog md which
is a youtube channel dedicated to
exploring similar themes to this channel
so if you like these podcasts there's a
great chance that you'll like his so
check out the link in the description
the main point of convergence between us
is consciousness it's because of this
that zubin interviewed me live on his
channel but the conversation was so
engrossing despite my
lastitude initially that i'm placing it
here
for those of you interested in
non-dualism meditation even fasting
for those new to this channel my name is
kurt jaimungle i'm a filmmaker with a
background in mathematical physics
dedicated to the explication of what are
called theories of everything
from a theoretical physics perspective
as well as the possible connection
consciousness has
to the fundamental laws of the universe
provided these laws exist at all and are
knowable to us
if you're interested in getting
acquainted with this channel there's a
top 10 list
of carefully curated videos in the
description it includes podcasts with
bernardo castro donald hoffman
ian mcgillcrist yoshibok and karl
fristen
more of course links are in the
description again if you'd like to hear
more conversations like this
for example soon i'll be speaking to leo
gura and even daniel schmottenberger
then please do consider going to
patreon.com
kurtjmungle and supporting it may sound
silly but literally every dollar helps
tremendously and it's wonderful
sometimes i receive letters saying
hey kurt this is just so that you don't
have to work so hard and perhaps you can
spend more time with your wife
because often i seclude my wife to a
room while i'm recording and i'm often
thinking about work so much that it
intrudes on our private time where i'm
not as present as i could be
there are a couple sponsors of today's
podcast algo is an end-to-end supply
chain optimization software company
with software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations
planning to avoid stock outs reduce
returns and inventory write-downs
while reducing inventory investment it's
a supply chain ai that drives smart roi
headed by a bright individual by the
name of amjad hussein who has been a
huge supporter of this podcast
from its early days the second sponsor
is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of
mathematics science and engineering with
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences
brilliance courses explore the laws that
shape our world elevating math and
science from something to be feared
to a delightful experience of guided
discovery more on them
later thank you and enjoy
first meeting is being recorded um
and anything off limits in what we talk
about
i'd say we just shoot the [ __ ] were you
okay with thumbnail and title and
everything
i'm fine with it all man i'm fine with
it and then
i'll just give you the footage and you
can do whatever you like with it put it
out
or not if you think it sucks whatever
you think makes sense
yeah and are you going to leave this
live stream up once it's done
yeah yeah uh
and and that way you have the kind of
raw thing that's shitty and then we have
the
really fancy produced version of either
one of us puts out
uh yeah and again just you just said and
the way i was thinking is like we're
talking to each other
so exactly this is just conversation no
one's interviewing
the other i'm all exactly we can talk
about this i'm a horrible interviewee
trust me
hey believe me so am i so so it'll be a
conversation
um let me do one thing here so what i
was thinking for the live and you can
tell me what your aesthetic is
by the way i watched your whole [ __ ]
documentary the two hour one
oh man holy [ __ ] hats off to you it's
experimental
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah it's off the rails
like
it's really [ __ ] intense and crazy
and awesome and
you said one thing well we should save
it for the show so um
uh um what i was thinking is i'll set it
to
speaker mode so that whoever's talking
gets full screen
just because the 69 side by side is a
little
jankety for the live i think at some
point i can put a side by side just to
mix it up but
i don't know what do you think just be
in the moment it's fine leave it as
the i think it's called the speaker view
yeah speaker view yeah that's perfect
that way it'll just go back and forth
between us for the for the live and then
obviously you can do anything we like
for the
replay um all right so we have all of
this
we're recording so you're recording your
audio as well
oh yeah it's all on the same uh track
it's it's embedded in the video track
but i can always break it out
uh but you can break it out as well i'll
just share it by dropbox with you
great um now let me think if there's
anything else okay now
so the only other tricky thing i do this
all myself so it gets a little
uh so we're going live to youtube and
facebook i've got it all teed up and i'm
going to share it on locals as well
so let me do a few clicks here and then
we'll just go live what do you think
yes go ahead i'm going to let you
introduce yourself if that's okay
because that'll just be the best
yeah yeah all right so
we're gonna do publish
all right theories of everything live
and then we're going to do
oh viewers are waiting look at that uh
let's do
how do i make this work i gotta go to
caster i gotta turn on
this that's how we simulcast is using a
company called caster
the cheap solution to simulcast there we
go so we're connecting to facebook live
perfect let me make sure facebook live
is work it is
all right and then i'm going to go live
in a couple clicks here so here we go
youtube
facebook and let's see how this works
guys
uh give it a second and we'll see if
we're live
it looks like we is on
facebook and youtube give me a second
here guys
welcome to the show it's the z dog and
kurt show today
kurt jeiman gal welcome brother thank
you so much for having me on man
i'm extremely glad to be here dude
this is a conversation i've been so
excited to have so
from parts of my audience that don't
know who kurt is
uh i watch his videos on youtube because
he interviews the kind of people that i
deeply care about hearing from and he
goes so deep i'm talking like the donald
hoffman's bernardo castro
talking to rupert spyra which was a
ridiculous like three or four hour
conversation and i watched all of it
and was just like this the whole time
kurt is a documentary filmmaker
and just a hey can you tell me a little
bit about yourself brother
yeah i'm a i'm a filmmaker first and
foremost
with a background in math and physics
and i've always been interested in what
are called theories of everything
which is a somewhat technical physics
term though it's now in common parlance
and it
usually in the physical sciences means
the unification of gravity with
the standard model as well as an ex
explanation for other
phenomena such as what is going on
inside of a black hole which you think
would be answered by
a quantum theory of gravity but not
necessarily what
is the beginning of the universe there's
differences as to what a theory of
everything
constitutes it doesn't matter you get
the va you get the overview
as for what i do with the channel as i
explore those
because i've always been interested in
theories of everything and luckily i
have some
i have some mathematical and physics
background so i can
do so with a certain level of depth and
i like to
question as deep as i possibly can the
guests that i speak to so
some of them have been they range from
theoretical physicists to people who are
espousers of the idea that consciousness
is primary
i explore theoretical physics free will
consciousness and god
oh my god okay that sounds like woo but
it depends on what the definition is
that's the channel
do you guys see why i love him like
like in a like want to marry him kind of
way so this these are exactly the same
things i'm interested in and
what's interesting kurt is like you know
i didn't have the physics and math
background that you have
um and i'm certainly not a documentary
filmmaker and
yeah but oh damn it hold on let me turn
up that noise
uh and i'm also if don't be put off but
the fact that i'm staring down at the
laptop
occasionally off at you and at the
camera because well i'm looking at
people's
comments too i'm impressed that you're
you've set up your camera such that
the ice the eye line is aligned with the
with me
so it looks like you're looking at me
whereas me i'm pointed downward
because well you know it's wonderful
it's one of those things that i've had
to i've had to work on for a long time
trying to figure it out what's weird is
it's very it's actually off-putting to
people on zoom who are used to zoom
culture
where it's kind of like hey kurt how's
it going uh
yeah things are good right and then
suddenly you're getting this weird
amounts of eye contact with
a background that isn't a um fake green
screen zoom background and people are
just
they're a little unnerved actually this
is something i wanted to ask you about
because
we can talk about the theories of
everything stuff which is important this
idea of um
is there unifying structure and and
conceptual framework that we can
understand everything with or is it a
infinite regress and that kind of thing
but but you know
even before that what's interesting is
you know in this since the pandemic
started
this medium that we use has just
exponentially blown up
is is that did you see your channel
really getting more engagement
post pandemic i it was started post
pandemic so
it was started during the pandemic we're
not posted but yes
there's a huge craving for discussions
that are
about the fundamental nature of reality
and perhaps that's because people are
philosophically destabilized they're in
them in a
mentally insecure place and i know i am
lubricus lubricus ground with regard to
belief at least for me
it's variable in a straddle and so
people are perhaps looking for certainty
and that's why they
come to these channels though if you're
looking for any answers i
i assure you i have virtually none in
the answer to almost any question that
zubin poses to me will be met with a
a dubious i don't know like i'm dubious
about my own dubiousness even
that that dubiousness about our own
dubiousness is this kind of meta
awareness or
it's it's the fundamental belief about
belief that everything
needs to be kind of questioned even our
dearest held
deepest and most hidden beliefs actually
i think to drew
into them and go okay but what if this
was not true
and actually what's present now in my
experience in what i can actually
detect now that that supports or refutes
this
belief even it may be a simple belief
like you know this
piece of z-dog md signs the crap out of
it merchandise which
i would feel like i'm shilling but we
don't sell it anymore uh
is separate from from me in some ways a
separate object in space and time that
space and time are real and these kind
of things and
actually the more you start to examine
those beliefs and actually
use the immediate experience the sensory
experience of this moment as a guide you
really start to destabilize
some of those beliefs that and and
bringing it back to what you were
talking about with the pandemic i found
the same thing i think people are
really fundamentally shook
by the fact that society is nothing
as nothing as stable as they thought it
was
that we're actually in an incredibly
fragile interconnected world that it
just
you know a blockage in the suez canal
ripples out and causes
my inability to wipe my ass with toilet
paper which
apparently is a near and dear need for
the western person
so much so that they hoard it when the
pandemic starts
so this destabilization i think has
forced some degree of introspection
that's been a long time coming
have you found the same thing in your
extensive pandemic travels
online yeah and conversely you just
mentioned
a disadvantage because you're connected
to what's
extremely outside you or seemingly so
but there's also some
it's also inspirational in a sense
because it means that your
loving nature to the degree that you
express it and your
truth-telling ability or at least
i would say it's more important to not
lie peterson has this
rule about tell the truth or at least
not lie i would flip that and say don't
lie
instead of not tell that instead of
telling the truth because it's extremely
easy to delude yourself into thinking
what you're doing is truth telling when
actually you're
well you're you're trying to
win an intellectual battle or show how
truth-telling you are by saying to
someone a mean comment
well either way that your ability to
that your loving nature can spread far
beyond you in the same way that
something
malicious can spread to you so it's a
twin
of both inspiration and horror
this idea of not lying
is something that i find really
interesting and of course sam harris
wrote his book called lying about
exactly this idea that there are this
there's a group of people that are
radical truth tellers you know they they
just will not they'll focus on not lying
and
what you mentioned about this idea of
love this idea of
a way of doing that compassionately i
think is key
because it's very easy to say okay you
know we use white lies to grease
so social situations to not hurt
somebody's feelings and so on and
and i think not telling all the truth is
a very different
sort of moral equivalent to telling a
say
telling an active lie to cover up
something that is true
um and actually in your in your
documentary which i i want to shout out
early on because it's
so crazy and experimental and awesome
the people who are into this should
check it out and i put a link in the
description it's better left
unsaid i believe you even said you know
you use that you had a quote where you
said you
you ask people for advice
when you know the answer right but the
answer is too painful
to actually accept so you ask someone
for advice that they'll they'll
hopefully tell you something different
or a white lie or something right
right i think that's emily jong although
i could be mispronouncing the name i
think you should remember
she had this quote that the only reason
you ask for advice is because you know
the answer
and you don't want to accept it so for
example some people will go to other
people for relationship advice hoping
that what they're hearing is
you should stay with that person when
you know deep down you shouldn't
what's your what's your take on
self-deception because
i think that we i think one of the
you know you you actually ended the
documentary with a beautiful
quote which i won't i won't give away
but
i think one of the fundamental problems
of our time
if we're going to emerge new systems
that are going to transform say let's
even just stick with my specialty health
care
if we're going to transform health care
we better [ __ ] transform ourselves
first
which means the self-deception the
lies we tell ourselves about ourselves
the hidden beliefs that we hold about
ourselves for example if we hold the
belief i'm a good person
right now it seems on the surface like a
wonderful belief
but when something when we do something
or think something
you know the thought arises something
that isn't nice
or we accidentally or purposefully do
something that's clearly
not in the best interest of someone else
and that
dissonance then generates a kind of
tension that
causes a weird kind of dysfunction
that actually projects outwards and i
think our
systems of human you know our human
systems are actually epiphenomenon of
our internal states and
until we can turn that lens inward
we're never going to solve these
external problems we're just going to
continue to
dysfunction out outwardly have you
thought quite a bit about this
i don't see another solution other than
extreme self-flagellation and
mortification self-mortification even to
say that any
anytime you think you're doing at least
for me anytime i think i'm a good
person oh i find
via examination that what i was doing
was cowardice
masquerading as something good or or
maliciousness or rancor
so i'm extremely hesitant to say that
anything i'm doing is good
i'm just trying to minimize the bad or
at least i'm trying to
try to minimize the bad
yeah i think that really involves
examining belief who am i
you know even that even that is a series
of nested beliefs that we hold in our
condition from
very young ages and are influenced by
everything around us and our genetics
right i'm not a big blank slate kind of
guy i think
a lot of who we are is passed on
uh genetically and otherwise and then
there's a component of environment but
really i i
i'm with pinker a little bit uh stephen
pinker on
this idea that we really are handed this
kind of
you know i'm going to use a loaded term
this karma not in a religious sense but
in the causes and conditions
that led to us and to some extent
there is a radical self-acceptance that
comes when you realize that you are as
you are and cannot be other
which means just that knowledge may
allow you a kind of freedom and
flexibility to be
better than you were but it it involves
actually accepting who you are instead
of constantly putting up obfuscation and
hiding from it and as a public person
and you are too and you've
your rise has been meteoric when i watch
your stuff
and actually this is something i should
i should say quick early on
when i saw your interview with hoffman
and castro now these are a couple of my
like the people that i i've interviewed
and
i watched those interviews and i was
like god damn
like this this guy's like a kid
he's vastly smarter incredibly handsome
and is asking these tremendously
nuanced questions and had these guys
attention and
and the audience attention for like
three hours of conversation
and my immediate response was rage
unworthiness jealousy anger
like all that just bubbles up i'm like
god i want to this guy needs to
fail right but but but the but the cool
thing i was proud of myself also it
warms my heart that's the malicious part
of me
the the part of me that um that that
is more meta-aware now from eight years
of being on a path of meditation and
that kind of thing was like oh look at
that
what's going on there like what part of
your ego is really
is has a sense of unworthiness or the
sense of like
you're never good enough and so on and
so forth and by examining that
like my next act was to send you an
email and go dude you're awesome
i love what you're doing and that
connected us and and you had sent me an
email prior to
because you had just reached out
spontaneously and it's very weird that
you have to you have to have some degree
of self-awareness to allow
things to happen that i think are
beneficial for all
but that requires the work you have to
actually put in the work i don't think
we're born that way there are very few
that are born that way
i certainly wasn't i am a complete
[ __ ] at baseline
complete [ __ ]
um i share your
animosity for those who succeed in a
domain that you think you should be
succeeding at a greater level than
the person who is i've come to the
and i haven't come to it but i'm coming
to this idea of
well love thy enemy and
there are some people especially in the
self-development scene because i used to
be a part of that
that i despise but i i think that the
reason i despise them is because i'm
jealous and so it
took almost everything out of me
everything from me to
click the like button on someone that i
hated
and i did that as i did that as a test
for myself
and there's this calm that comes at
least over myself
after i
i tell this story plenty so some people
ask me how are you supposed to
solve this whole extreme left extreme
right divide
and someone was interviewing me on the
radio recently
yesterday or or so i believe he said
he wanted me to say what because he's
against the extreme left
and he wanted and usually the people who
are adamantly against the extreme left
identify with being
a part of the right or even extreme
right and he wanted me to say that what
we need to do is
fight back and i'm i'm forced standing
up for oneself and saying what
one believes i think that's noble and
extremely difficult
but i don't advocate for any fighting i
advocate for extending an arm of love to
one's enemy in the same way that there's
the story of
of jesus and i'm not saying this as a
christian i'm not christian
i'm saying this as as
as as the teller of a story that if you
truly thought about it would bring you
to tears
when jesus was being taken away by
people who
he knew at least according to the story
we're going to torture him kill him
peter who was his friend cut off the ear
of the soldier who was taking him away
and jesus said no
and took the ear and healed his enemy
and like
that kind of love man to be shouted at
and still say
and not in a condescending way because
it can easily be constant i love you
despite you
no but mean it and heal your enemy
i think that's even despite knowing what
they're doing to you i think that's
the path forward and obviously someone
can say well then we'll just be taken
over by
by brutal dictators the bullies i don't
think that's true i think that these
tit-for-tat models don't take into
account inspiration the story of jesus
is inspirational
so these separate agents who can
interact with one another
with different strategies such as
tit-for-tat or tit-for-tat with
forgiveness i'm sure you've heard of
these models the people who are
listening
i don't think they take into account
inspiration how one agent
if one agent identifies with themselves
then then they die
but if one identifies with what's good
then one lives because
the good lives on through you through
your example and through influencing
others
so i i'm not claiming that i live by
that but i'm coming to that realization
more and more
trying or at least trying to try to
embody it
i i try to end every show we do with uh
i love you guys
and we're out and and mean it like
actually mean it
like i love everybody as they are myself
which gets to you know one of those
interesting philosophical and
ontological questions of what is the
nature of reality
if are we one substance
is there one mind and you talked to
castrip and hoffman and spyra about it
and
i'm just curious where having talked to
all these guys and and
physicists and having this mathematical
and physics
uh physicist background you know in your
documentary you were very
it was really remarkable to watch
because and again
for some people they're just gonna be
like i don't what the hell
and for others you know like myself i
was just like oh
i've never actually connected the dots
in the way that he's connecting it
and by the end you know i watched the
long director's cut it's two hours
you you said what's the minimum amount
of information necessary
to extract the information and the
meaning from the message
and i thought that was a fascinating
experiment because
you know two four six eight like how how
much do you need to get the rest of the
pattern
and your point was well maybe when we
look at something like the bible and
and and we think oh you know this whole
thing could be reduced to the ten
commandments
or you know or the golden rule which is
something i despise
i mean i despise people saying that
that's what connects all religions and
that's all we need
and i can talk about that after but
continue oh let's definitely that's
definitely father because that's great
the golden rule
so yeah and there's this idea but then
but then you say but but is that really
true
because this was written first of all in
a time in a context that's different
from where we are
now could the meaning have only
emerged from a length that's roughly the
length of the bible say
and we're just not really savvy to to
that
maybe something was lost in the
translations and so on but and and then
you
you tied it back maybe that's why this
documentary is two hours long
and it kind of tied the whole thing into
a tapestry and i don't know if you did
that intentionally or not but
yeah maybe you want to talk about that
and then bring it back to golden rule
and you're concerned with that
okay let's talk about the i would also
talk about the length of the bible
or the ancient text in general and i'd
say that not only is the length of the
bible
maybe not protracted as much people as
plenty of people think but
it's necessary and also not not
sufficient so it's one
well how do you get that see apparently
they're
not apparently there's something called
the
protestants who were driven by sola
scriptorus meaning
by scripture alone i don't know if i
buy that because plenty of our
values and well
our values are also embodied now i
referenced this in the
documentary there are four forms of
knowing at least four forms
propositional
that is i'm speaking right now if you
were to simply read it that's
propositional
procedural i'm just i'm just speculating
so
there's a mod at least a modicum of body
language though
the research says that it's 70 and i
don't understand how they get that
number
but because how do you quantify what the
message is and so
okay there's that then there's
participatory and then
forgive my lastitude it's
it's been quite a grueling week
for me yeah you you've not slept
right i haven't slept well for a few
days and i've been on this string of
podcasts this is the fourth one for
today
and after this i'm not looking forward
to this ending i actually want to speak
with you for like three hours if i can
but after this zubin i am going to just
it's i'm going to feel like like a
junkie that just put heroin in
my body and and just
be dissolving a sea of bliss for
hopefully a week or two weeks because i
need a break okay
we can talk about that after getting to
the four
forms of knowing is there's
participatory procedural
perspectival and propositional
it's not clear to me that
religion is propositional per se and i
know the new atheists like to pick apart
texts
and literally interpret it and there's a
word there's a great word to
if you don't know it's called subraption
it means an inference drawn from
a deliberate deliberate
misrepresentation and so
what they're doing is when they disprove
the bible they're
they're using subraptions and i don't
think that's true firstly i don't think
the bible's meant to be interpreted
literally i also have a problem with the
word literal interpretation
because you can't have a literal
interpretation literal means
uninterpreted so it's almost as if
you're saying uninterpreted
interpretation
and then a third it's not clear that all
of what a religion is is in the text so
i'm not a fan of sola script
taurus per se solis scriptura i think it
is
yeah well i want to go back to your
sleep
so yes yeah how's that going
well why so bad and and because you're
desperate for some uh
some rest and i think a lot of people in
healthcare in particular suffer this
syndrome what's been going on what's
driving you and
how's your sleeping and all of that
i find it difficult to shut my mind off
i have tried meditation for
years but not consistently
i don't find it helps i also find that
people who
you probably see this people in the
non-dual community
people who are eastern people who are
west they think that their view is the
correct one and they try to blanketly
apply it to everyone i don't know if
it's if meditation is for everyone and i
wonder
part of my self-torture is by trying to
impose meditation on me when i'm
at this stage not meant for meditation
it could be that it could be i'm
not meditating correctly but either way
meditation doesn't help
medication can help but i'm not going to
take benzodiazepines though melatonin
works a scintilla cbd
seems to work a bit either way what's
kept what keeps me up is
generally if i have an interview for the
next few days i'm playing over scenarios
and i'm trying to
understand the theory of the person that
i'm interviewing
that's one of the i was speaking with a
prominent youtuber
i'll tell you off air who that is zubin
he was asking me he's like hey kurt i
have more subscribers than you but you
have more views
how is it that you do so and then i said
it's extreme luck which it is like
95 luck man and then also an extreme
amount of work
and the work is because i'm trying to
understand
i'm trying to comprehend these theories
the whole point of the podcast it's not
i don't care too much about conversing
with people i care about understanding
the
landscape of theories of everything
explicating them and perhaps even
advancing
our own and i say our own because the
theories of everything
youtube is almost like a community and
and i'm
i would like it to be a i would like
myself to be a vessel rather than the
prominent person of it in fact i think
i think there are some youtube channels
that have had a nominal have had
a name that's tangential to what they do
and then their name attached so let's
say i'm
going to pick on some people but please
of your these two youtubers
i love you okay so there's artificial
intelligence with lex friedman
and then there was modern wisdom with
chris williamson
and then what they do is they remove the
prior and then
just they omit that and keep their name
i am
toying with doing the opposite because i
don't want this to be about me so maybe
eventually you'll be theories of
everything
obviously there's some of me that's
doing a bit of branding by keeping my
name in the channel
but at some point i'd like to truncate
that either way i'm sure the whole point
of the channel is to explore
theories of everything everything so i'm
deeply ensconcing myself in these
theories
and it takes they're not trivial
not trivial in the least in fact try
reading
three pages of what chris langan has
written that took me a day to get
through three pages
and it gets gets quicker obviously as
you get familiar with the terminology
but i'm trying to understand these and
so
i was talking to someone who's a
prominent youtuber and he was saying hey
kurt
your channel has less
subscribers but more views how i said
it's nice it's like luck and then work
extreme amount of work and he got
offended at the extreme amount of work
aspect he said well my work doesn't
drain me i just listen to them i listen
to guests on podcasts i go for
i do it when i while i meditate or while
i'm doing the dishes in fact it
invigorates me and it was as if he was
offended that i said
that the work that i do drains me and
i do think what i'm doing right now the
way that i'm doing it is unhealthy
obviously because i'm
barely able to articulate a sentence
here
but but i don't see right now i don't
see another way around
around this given the goal of deeply
trying to understand these theories of
everything
so that affects my sleep at times
luckily zubin
after this man i just i'm going i'm
going to rest for like i'm i'm going to
hibernate for a little while
man i i how old are you kurt can i ask
yeah sure how old do i look and you're
not gonna offend me
oh man you look like you're in your 20s
dude no
i'm 32. really well dude
so you're still 32 to me is it is is
very young
uh and when i was your age my mind
was so overactive and and i i was like
you
very diligent and very uh wrapped in the
intellectual aspects the thinking
process and the making the connections
and
if i closed my eyes a million thoughts
and a million connections and
with that came with that kind of
capacity comes high anxiety
so sleep was not there it just didn't
happen and
the the that sort of phenotype of person
i kind of see it in you when i see your
interviews because i can tell
i think most of the audience can tell
that you've put a [ __ ] ton of work
into these guests like the fact that you
can talk for
you know three or four hours to somebody
who's esoteric to begin with
right is is pretty remarkable
there's no answer for that right away
the answer starts to emerge as you
become more absolutely i agree
yeah you any if i were to tell you bro
you just need to realize that you're
just pure consciousness man and these
thoughts are just going across the sky
like clouds
and you can watch them good luck with
that try that just try that
at this stage we're identified with the
thought stream
and the thought stream is everything
and in a way that's awesome because
that's how we
like the guy who was offended by the
amount of diligence you'd really want to
introspect and go okay why is that is it
is it is he threatened by someone who
can work hard and is talented or is he
is he more really convinced that his way
is the only way
i'll tell you when when you tell me that
i go ah
that's why it's combination of things
why your stuff is so good
i have at this age i'm 48
so it took me i don't know how many
decades to
release how old are you sorry
i'm uh 48. so
it took me however many decades to
release this fixation that i had on
hyper diligence as a way to get by
and but i needed it if i didn't have it
i wouldn't have the tool
tool set that i have to do what i do and
now what i do is i try to drop into
flow and see what happens sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't there's some
part of the audience that loves that
there's some part of the audience that
really wants a more
structured sort of thing but i can't be
anything but what i am in this moment
now
it used to be i would try not to be i
try to be whatever anyone wanted
which was very it was very ego
dystonic it felt very wrong but yet you
get the dopamine burst from whatever
validation that came from doing that so
it really took a lot of time for me to
find that way
and i'm not saying that's your path but
i think that i'm very sympathetic to
what you're going through
it's very hard very very hard um
your your documentary by the way for
people who have not seen it
it really speaks to who you are it it
there's so many gems in there of
kind of getting at who kurt is right now
that it's it's
absolutely a fascinating thing to watch
and and when you talk about your parents
i thought that was fascinating because
i resonated with one of the things he
said and i don't know if you said this
consciously or
as just part of who you are you said you
know i really the idea that i they may
not be around to kind of see what i've
accomplished and that kind of thing i'm
like
that's that's an immigrant thing man
like for me
like this idea that so much of my life i
lived like what am i gonna do to
to show my parents that i'm worthy of
being a kid of theirs
and and then at some point something
snaps
i think maybe you do actually accomplish
enough or you let it go but then
suddenly it's like
how can i show you i'm just like doing
as little as possible and just trying to
be me
you know because i think that's
ultimately what we all you know
what i was looking for but yeah i got to
change my headphones and i want to hear
you
through this stream of consciousness
just give me a second all right
yeah of course so while you're doing
that i'm going to look at some comments
here
um boy there's a lot of comments uh
too much at one time try separating the
now to what can wait says ann
cairns so that's always that's good
advice for anyone it's very hard for an
autonomic mind because we're not really
we
see so here's one of the things that i
thought of you know when i was hearing
you talk about this
there is for me when that happens
oh yeah sure sure um
can you hear me now though or no ah now
you can hear me yeah
all right we're going to find out
because i don't want to talk great yeah
yeah okay i can hear you chris yeah
you can hear me i don't know if okay i
don't know if anyone
can help me with this tech problem
anytime i use obs which is recording
right now
there's distortion placed on the head on
the bluetooth headphones
don't know why that is okay continue
yeah i use obs for streaming live but
not in this case because i'm
using um caster but i found that obs is
very quirky since it's open
source there's some weird stuff in there
that yeah people may know the answer
okay so so one thing you said when you
talked about this thought
storm that you have at night
that prevents you from sleeping i i
actually
think of that as a storm of thought for
many people
myself as one of these we
hold ourselves accountable for having
the thought storm and it wraps a series
of meta beliefs around
what's actually happening so thoughts
are coming and then we go these thoughts
shouldn't be coming so fast i should be
sleeping right now
why can't i turn the thoughts off why am
i having these thoughts i'm
somehow a bad person or i'm not good
enough or whatever and
that adds another layer because as as
you probably know from talking to so
many people that you've talked to we
don't author our thoughts
in fact any level of investigation can
kind of reveal pretty quickly that these
thoughts arise
they may be from causes and conditions
but we're not the author of them in
other words
we cannot control what we think because
even trying to do that actually causes
more thoughts to
ripple in the pond of consciousness that
doesn't mean we can't frame our response
to the thoughts
or how we kind of interpret our our
thought storm
but we certainly can't control the
actual thoughts that arise and
that illusion of control which again
relates to free will and all that
which is a whole another thing but
that'll we're going to talk about that
yeah we should definitely talk about
that that illusion of control it
creates a kind of suffering it's a kind
of a meta-suffering on top of the
suffering of
identifying with the thoughts so it's
very hard to tease those things out it's
only
recently that i've been able to watch my
mind enough
with a lot of help from different
resources that to go oh look what's
happening
this is a thought storm you know okay
okay don't don't i'm not going to judge
myself for the thought storm and what's
weird is
the thought storm then kind of runs its
course so now when i wake up at 3 a.m
with this feeling of like pressure in
the chest
this unknown source of anxiety right
that clearly has some cause and
condition that i can't pinpoint
and then the thought storm launches oh
my god why am i anxious why am i so
anxious oh i have an interview today
oh man what am i going to do in this
interview and then the thoughts start
secreting like the sponge of the mind
squeezes and it just secretes
these thoughts i'm able to actually at
some point get a meta-aware
metacognition and go oh look at this
look what's happening okay
okay when you say you're able to do that
how are you
able to do that without exercising free
will
so this is where i find free will is a
fascinating
fascinating thing so you know i we
know the arguments against free will we
know arguments for determinism that
everything is just causes and conditions
then we're just along for the ride
but actually i'm increasingly wondering
whether
how we direct our attention
is not one of the only things within
some degree of will now
hoffman with his conscious agent theory
actually feels that
each agent within the complex
instantiation that we are has its own
de novo uh uh
free will but it's constrained by the
free will decisions of
other agents within the matrix and
therefore
true likes free will at this
instantiation isn't really true it's
constrained
but yet novelty still enters the
universe in the form of decisions
at each level and so i think free will's
i don't think there is no free will i
think free will is not what we think it
is
i think it is and i'm not a
compatibilist or something like dennett
i just don't think it's what we think it
is so there's
a something that happens and you could
even say this well even that's not free
will when i'm
recognizing the thought storm and i'm
deciding to do this thing
it's more that this neuronal storm this
complex series of
of happenings that is me suddenly
because of previous causes and
conditions i read a text
i studied some buddhism i read sam
harris's book on free
will i studied angela de lulo's book on
awakening
and now there's enough juice there to
emerge a decision to go
a decision that's mine to go oh this is
this thought storm i should
sit back and watch it and then let it
dissipate so it's very
complex and i think even claiming to
understand it would be
just pure foolishness
so in what you just articulated it's
more about that we don't have free will
it's that our decisions are based upon
the prior conditions and these
are also not within our control
i would say this i i'm actually kind of
partial to the buddhist
idea of dependent origination that
everything happens
because of causes and conditions that
aren't simple it's not just
i lift up the cup therefore this happens
it's more like the entire web is
connected
in ways that even the super super
computer can't could never predict yet
and that then you know
unified vibration of stuff happening
affects what
thought arises next have you heard of
wolfram's concept of computational
irreducibility
i haven't okay so what it is it's it's
wolfram thinks that this is the origin
of free will
computational irreducibility means that
a system is you can't predict the
outcome of a system without running the
system
and because we're embedded within the
system that we're running you can't
predict your own actions
unless you simply run them almost like
a simple example is
fluid dynamics it's difficult to know
what's
where a certain particle is going to end
up unless you just simulate it
you can't derive it and
right okay well then he would say that
that's the origin of free will i don't
it sounds
similar to what you're saying okay i
love that
and i'll tell you why because you know
there's i think there's
i don't know if it's fmri data or what
but human minds
simulate out what they're going to do
and in fact i think sam harris has
talked about this
we you know if i if i go i want to pick
up this cup
my mind has already done a projection
this is what it looks like and it lights
up motor sections of the brain that
would normally be involved in actually
picking up that cup
so in a way our mind is like a future
predictor but
that act of prediction feels to the to
the consciousness that we are
like a free will decision it's almost
like
it you know it predict you know and
these studies have been decided you know
you know
you've made a decision like up to six
seconds on fmri before you're aware the
decision has been made
but that doesn't mean that some aspect
of your mind system hasn't
hasn't con hasn't in a free will sense
de novo made a decision
that you're just not aware of at this
level of consciousness where we are
and that's why you know we have all
these unconscious processes that in
themselves may well be
conscious at their level in a way we are
not able to experience without
brain damage drugs whatever that put us
at that level
um so free will becomes this intensely
complex
thing to even think about and and one
thing i want i want to say is
if you've ever had a meditative
experience and it's not really
meditative it's more a non-dual
experience
and what i mean by that is
and i i can actually try to put myself
in this headspace even now
where and there's a beautiful
old piece of wisdom writing a buddha
suta called the bahia suta
that that points this out and
and it goes like this train yourself
this way
is what this wise sage is telling
someone who's trying to learn to be
enlightened
and he says train yourself in this way
in the scene
there will merely be what is seen
in the herd there will merely be what is
heard
in the thought there will merely
be the thought and so on through the
six senses which the sixth is mind
and the idea there is notice what isn't
there
is a you an i
a perceiver when they say in the scene
there will merely be what is seen it
means that
there is just seeing so this cup
is just this self-knowing
self-illuminating
happening now when you drop into
that state the self cannot be found
there's no eye having the experience
experience
is experiencing appearances appearancing
and
that feels like a kind of sense of
agency that is very different
than what we classically call free will
because there's
nobody making the decisions that things
are happening things are just happening
to no one but there's a sense
of an is-ness where everything is just
okay
it's very hard to put into words in fact
i don't think you can put it into words
so this is not saying that there is no
self this is saying that
the thoughts that you traditionally
identify with yourself are not you
something like that or is is this an
a statement for the dissolution of the
idea of self
at all so it's even beyond that
it's that there's no experiencer
so do you know how rupert spyro will
talk about
step back as be the awareness the sense
of i
am the consciousness is what we are
is his one of his teachings right
there's a step beyond that which is even
consciousness as a subject as an
experiencer
disappears and then even the idea of
self
it's it's nowhere to be found there's no
you there and and it's very hard to put
into words but
what that feels like is
things happening and that includes sound
sight hearing smell taste and thoughts
so thoughts materialize and they're
they just are what they are so
everything is just appearing
but there's no subject and it's not even
that the idea disappears is that even
the co
there's nothing there it's just stuff
happening and the way that feels is
infinite okayness infinite freedom
and no suffering and the reason there's
no suffering is
who's the subject of suffering so even
if a painful sensation
arises it's just experienced in and of
itself
as exactly what was happening in its
right place
to no one which again it sounds crazy
when you try to put it into language
which by its nature is a dualizing
subject object construction when you say
that it feels okay who's it feeling okay
too why is there no
experience or there
you could say it this way and again even
this is not doing it justice and people
who've had this experience are going to
be laughing at me going this asshole's
trying to explain this
in words and you can't i understand i
mean you can think of it you can think
of it
yeah it's very tough you can think of it
this way pain
is just it's a self-illuminating
process in other words it's a vibrating
field of experience that just
is in and of itself without the need for
a subject
so it's truly non-dual meaning not to
there's no subject and object there's
just this so
if we were to just stare at this you
know
this object attention in a way the beam
of attention that feels like it's coming
from a subject to an
object that evaporates and the object
just
radiates its own being
in a way that feels more real than
anything that you
could experience as an experiencer and
the thing is to come from that state and
then try to
describe it is absolutely not
possible all you can do is point with
words
to evoke that natural state in people
but even that you have to be really good
at that like rupert's very good at that
there are people that can point very
directly muji on youtube is
very very good at pointing very directly
um
adi ashanti might be good at pointing
very directly
and and when you experience it and
people experience it in flow state oh my
i disappeared and things were just
happening it was this just beautiful
flow
and all they come back and go i want
that again because
when you experience it you have this
weird intuition and again who is this
you
language will fail us there's an
intuition that this is what
everybody's been talking about and
seeking throughout all time
when we look at any spiritual or wisdom
pursuit
and i've only had sort of unstable
short-term glimpses of this and when
i've come back i've been like
oh the ego immediately reasserts itself
and goes oh i'm the guy that had that
experience that was dope
i'm gonna tell stories about it right
it's really interesting but in the
moment you're just like
it's just pure wonder
personless just oh and
then you come back and the mind comes
and tells a story about it because it
has to
there's nothing else it can do he has no
words for it you made
an argument as to why we shouldn't
experience pain when we're in that state
you use the word vibration i don't
recall what the exact
statement was but why can't we not use
that same argument to say that
even the feeling of bliss when you're in
that state is an illusion
and there's no bliss either so i
i would put it this way all that is in
that state
is what is so the raw experience the
unfiltered reality of what's happening
at that moment
and whether it's a sensory experience
like the sensation of pain
we call it pain because we apply this
conceptual label to that experience
we say pain which has a charge of
valence of negative
and then a response of avoidance or
projecting a thought into the future
when will this pain go away
or a memory oh this feels like that time
i had you know appendicitis or whatever
without all that overlay it's just
this sensation happening in
now to no one and that's the other thing
is time
is not even if there's no
conceptualization of time
so it's just all happening as a kind of
a wave
right now now that can sound
disconcerting and actually anyone who's
done psychedelics at any point
may have had experiences like this and
then come back to sobriety and said oh
man i was just
tripping balls but what you may have
touched into
is the timeless nature of raw experience
without the conceptual overlay and what
that
feels like to a mind when it comes back
is oh i was tripping balls
right but in reality it's really one of
the most natural
it's probably the natural state prior to
mind imposing itself
in in my opinion because i can only
speak from my own experience
well you can't speak for your own
experience if there's no you
so when you say that that's just a
linguistic device it's a linguistic
device
exactly and by the way kurt so people
the the non-dual people do these
linguistic gymnastics around trying to
not use the word eye and all that that's
dumb
i think language is designed for
a wee space right so you have to use
language to try to describe something
undescribable and all you can do is
point in the direction only you can kind
of
have the experience the and by you even
that
right you see where the language fails
pretty quickly
are you of the belief that what lies at
the immaterial fundamental level is
something like a non-dual
vellum just this one sheet and it's
undifferentiated
it's so hard to make metaphysical
onological claims about the nature of
reality
without invoking belief because
you said it their belief is it your
belief and belief is another thought
it's another conceptual label on
experience i would say this
i've been un so from an intellectual
side i've been uncompelled by the
materialist paradigm
yeah that that and feel free to
interrupt me yeah i was going to say you
mentioned that belief is a conceptual
thought i don't buy that
i don't think that that's the case i
think that we think it is and i think
that's part of the problem
because for example if you say i believe
that i'm in a i believe the stove is
is not hot but then you say well put
your hand on it then
it's red and then you're like no no i'm
not going to i would say you believe
with your body
your actions belie your beliefs so what
you say with your mouth doesn't match
what
doesn't match your actions and your
actions are your true test of belief
and if it's embodied then your beliefs
aren't simply con
concepts aren't simply abstractions
so the unconscious response of the body
and remember i actually wonder whether
the body itself is not
just part of a continuum of
consciousness with its own
belief conditioning and maybe you may be
right that it's not a
thought-based conceptual thing as much
as it is an
overlay on experience because let's
think of it this way
i don't believe okay let's take the
belief out of it putting my hand on that
hot stove
right i'm going to do it now right
okay my belief from conditioning from
experience
and from what what the body is
autonomically telling me that's been
conditioned into my unconscious
for into my reflex patterns right is
this is bad
this hurts must stop not good okay
there's the belief component of it
in a in a if i didn't have those
reflexes
and i'm experiencing unfiltered reality
i would just experience the
vibrating temperature field of that
experience
which the mind would then say this is
terrible you need to stop now you're
dying and
you would then smell the burning flesh
which would be a pure sensory experience
so
in other words there's a
conceptualization that the mind does
to raw data from from the sense field
that's necessary and it's so fundamental
to us being human
that that you're you're saying well i
think it's more fundamental than that is
not wrong
i just think there's one level even
beyond more fundamental than that and
that's just the raw
unfiltered reality that that just is and
we couldn't function
i think just experiencing unfiltered
reality like that all the time we
wouldn't be able to get across the
street
which is why i think these structures of
consciousness evolve
i understand that one can get to a place
where one
feels like
there is no pain and but
to me that's a different claim than
saying that there is no pain
that's the claim that i get i've gotten
to a place where i experience
no pain where traditionally pain would
be felt like these buddhist monks who
can light themselves
on fire that's that to me seems like
well what i'm about to say is
contradictory but
that to me seems like an adaptive
strategy rather than an
ontological claim like one can
it's like a tool meditation may even be
a tool rather than
and we're mixing up the tool with a
claim about reality i don't know i'm
just saying that
i'm unconvinced in each direction now
let me ask you a question about this
when
given that the mind is self-deceptive
and we know this and experience is
fallible or at least the inferences
drawn from experiences
are fallible then why would one make the
claim that just because i can get to a
state where i feel like the self is an
illusion
that the self is an illusion given that
the self seems to be the most pernicious
and
pernicious illusion and yet
we've dispensed with it how do you know
that that's itself is not an illusion
right so this gets to the question of
like where how deep do you have to go
before you can convince yourself that
something
isn't illusory and i think
neuroscientists
i think could say well there's no seat
of the self even
neuro neurophysiologically there's no
little homunculus in the mind where it's
it's the
thing that's the point where you know
you're sitting behind your mind you can
look at default mode network and go okay
a lot of our
our discursive thought about self our
ideas of self and our inward ruminations
uh kind of originate in the default mode
network which itself is not a point it's
a diffuse
kind of body of things and there are
aspects of that even
i actually think that and again it so
some of this comes from
experiencing these states and the
question is how what what truth can you
pull out of that
and when you talk about even meditation
as a tool like you're lighting yourself
on fire
i think there is a component of you can
there are meditative practices and
genres and things like that where you
can
actually you get very good at ignoring
sensory stimulation to where it doesn't
distract you
and that's very different than allowing
yourself to experience the raw
experience of being on fire and doing
nothing about it
so again without having gone through
that it's very hard to investigate
because the way you would have to
there's no way to investigate these
easily without doing it
introspectively because it refers to
interstates
but then how much can you extrapolate
out and i think harris struggles with
this so he'll always put the disclaimer
well you know i'm making no claims about
the nature of the universe i'm just
saying this
whereas deepak chopra takes the opposite
tact and says well
because i've experienced this in
meditation it must be true of the whole
universe
right and i think both of those are very
extreme statements i think what you have
to do is you have to kind of
again approach it scientifically and say
okay so what what would a materialist
paradigm say about
the nature of self is the self a real
thing
well i think even materialists will say
well no it's probably a construction
that's made by neurochemical processes
in the brain that themselves are not
conscious so how is that any more real
than saying yeah the self is actually a
mind construct made up of thought
belief and it's a very tight web of
thought going to thought going to
thought
that's conditioned from birth that's all
made of consciousness and it can be seen
through
it can actually relax it never goes away
really
it can relax and get out of the way of
raw experience i'm not sure there's a
big distinction there i i
which is why i'm increasingly convinced
that
that when people talk about awakening
say spiritual awakening
really a big piece of that i think
is the dropping away off the
false sense that i am this
to go to the next level of i am this
which is
consciousness itself and then even that
collapses into
what i am nothing just this
so just this happening
and it you this is where you can't even
open your mouth about it
because there's no you to
and i think that look look kurt like if
this were easy to talk about
it'd be one of those things we'd all be
pretty awake because we just in school
we'd be like okay so here's the thing
all right
do these three things yourself drops
away you see truth as it is
if only yeah yeah okay i'm unsure
i know that there's the claim of of what
one cannot speak of specifically one
must be silent
that's wittgenstein and it's also true
that
it could be that our level of language
is not
sophisticated enough so for example go
back
ten thousand years well that's not
enough for grunts but let's go back to
caveman
era when they're grunts obviously they
lacked a level of
language that would
allow them to understand what a
microphone is for example or what uh
or what any sufficiently comp almost
anything in this place they wouldn't be
able to understand it in the same way we
do because they don't have the language
for it so there's a relationship between
language and thought
and when people say that uh that well we
can't speak of it i
i say we can't speak of it now i'm not
saying that i don't think that
necessarily i don't see the reason why
language would necessarily
be incapable of expressing the thought
of
the thoughts that one gets to in these
meditative spaces
either way it doesn't matter that that
doesn't matter okay actually
i think i think that's an important
point that you bring up
because everything that you just talked
about
is coming at this state from a position
of mind
so in other words from the position of
the the
the linguistic mind which as you say is
this is important
cognition and language are not to
talk about non-dual they're directly
related in your documentary i think you
interviewed a dude
who was talking about that actually
quite directly uh
i'm forgetting his name now but this
idea that
so this is what i propose to you kurt um
you may be right like i can't disprove
what you're saying but i can
only say this from the experience of
that state
i can say pretty firmly coming back and
then using language
i said i i i it's not a
words thing uh and and the only way you
will be able to understand that argument
is by experiencing the state which again
is it's actually not difficult to get to
but you have to be pointed in a way
and open in a way and you have to almost
surrender the resistance of
all our conditioning which that's what
makes it hard and
i struggle with it i struggle and and
the problem is when you come back
to the standard mind state from that
more open surrendered
your mind starts to tell stories
immediately
about how you're not worthy to ever get
that back
so i completely understand at some point
if you just read the dictionary
only refers to other words so in a sense
almost every concept
needs what's extra linguistic because
you can't talk about what's bumpy let's
say
by reading the dictionary you have to
point to what's bumpy experience it
attach the label of bumpiness
so maybe because this these states are
so rare for
the majority of people attaching a name
is
extremely difficult if not impossible i
don't know if it's impossible
but i understand that it's difficult you
know what's interesting
in your again in your documentary going
back to this because i think because
let's see this is important
how do we we started off talking about
how are we going to how's the world
going to emerge better
systems if we don't actually understand
ourselves well
you know your theories of everything are
crucial but they have to include
the internal universe of human
experience i think that's my opinion
and and the question is how do we
develop ways to point to
these truths from people who've had
those
are operating from that position so
they're operating from that present
moment
sort of experience and i've met a couple
people who are
who do that and just talking to them can
evoke the state and
and i interviewed one of them angelo
delulo who's an anesthesiologist
he had an awakening in 97 since then
he's further 97
97 so he's my age he's 48
this is crazy talk about jealousy dude
talk about jealousy i was like
screw you buddy so the re but the reason
he had an awakening is he
suffered he was suffering so much
internally with all the just angst and
existential drugs 97 he was suffering
in in 1997. oh 1997.
not at the age of 97. sorry no no he's
he's my age but it was back in 97
and he never he had this experience
where the self-dissolved he was
pure emptiness like the substratum that
the universe appears from from nothing
uh the idea of buddhist emptiness
doesn't even even kind of touch what he
had experienced he told me and
this this then he never spoke of to
anyone because he found he couldn't say
a word about it
and it took him 20 years of further work
including going through medical school
becoming an anesthesiologist
like experiencing everything in the
human condition reasserting his
suffering and everything to be able to
better understand how to point to it and
even then he said it's really really
difficult but just being around
him can invoke those states at least it
does in many people who've talked to him
including myself because i had him in my
studio for two days straight
and i tell you i was walking around like
i was on lsd
for a good three days afterwards and
even my family was like
wow you're a different person it's
really a
it's a real thing and so how how would
we begin to use
language or the tools that we have to
try to
emerge that and i don't have the answers
for that but i think it's something we
ought to be
looking into with your cup it says
science the heck out of this or
something like that do you mind showing
it to the camera
sure it's uh science the crap out of it
right right right okay do you believe
that the reason why i say that
is because what you've just described
has almost nothing to do with science in
fact it seems anti-science to go
to one's experience the subjective
rather than the objective
so so what's the deal with that cup and
how can
do you when was that cup made was that
before this
three-day spa with this person nope
it's yes and science is absolutely
the study of the external third person
or internal singular physical physical
icon world and again to put it in
in buddhist language the causes and
conditions the dependent origination
what what are the rules of that why does
why does the manifest world behave the
way it does and
science and i'm a deep adherent of this
as a physician and as someone who
advocates science-based medicine and so
on
but that is a yes and so
even trans-rational thought it's not
thought
this experience of like well okay so
what's the sub-stratum then that even
encompasses science and that's what i'm
pointing out
with what i'm saying but science is
still absolutely valid at that relative
level of
existence which is what matters to most
humans because
like us even being able to talk is
understandings of quantum mechanics and
understandings of electro
electronics and wi-fi and all that so
and medicine so this is where it gets
the intersection with medicine
medicine has gone a long way using the
reductionist scientific method
reductionist meaning and that's a very
charged word
i don't really like it it's more saying
okay we're it's a materialist paradigm
there are receptors and gates and
molecules
dna and so on and if we understand that
we'll be able to do anything in medicine
and i actually disagree because i think
what we're seeing there
is what hoffman calls our interface and
we can get narrow and narrower in terms
of the pixel density of the interface
but at some point we cannot get down
underneath it to the transistors and
electron gates that are actually
running the desktop so that's where the
understanding of awareness
consciousness and introspection is the
next
science for lack of a better term i'm so
glad you talked about this
zubin something i've been thinking about
for quite some time is what is and i
don't like to say this i
talked about this at the i was speaking
to previously
what is science 2.0 in essence theories
of everything is
the project is it's teetering on the
edge of that question
think about the science 400 years ago
it's not the same science now it wasn't
even called science and then so science
developed so then you can wonder well
where is it headed and then by what
criteria does what
does one include this into science
versus not science i call it
abhijnasis which is a mouthful but it's
a merging of gnosis which is
knowledge in the western sense and then
which is knowledge in the eastern sense
i'm not even sure if that's correct
maybe there's a
trichotomy rather than a duality
but either way this whole investigation
is to what is the next science and you
just mentioned well science is so-and-so
but i also think
is an investigation not of reality but
of objective reality as it's currently
defined because you require
inter-subjective
agreement so agreement between plenty of
people and right now
you've had experiences that i have i can
only
glimpse at a at a scintilla of
understanding
so we don't have intercept subjective
agreement with this
but it is still part of reality your
experience is part of reality
that's not captured in science so that's
why i was saying
it depends on what you call science with
your cup if you if whether or not you
want to follow it
additionally you mentioned as a
physician and i think
i think any science outside of the hard
sciences like math and physics
are in the realm of ethics because you
obvi you have to apply it in the world
of action
so you have to say is this intervention
worth it and over there you have a value
judgment
science would just say if then statement
so if you give this person this will
happen if this if this if this if this
you then have to select between them
which is a
it's a moral hierarchy it's an ethic and
i don't see that as incorporated into
science per se
so please let me hear your thoughts on
that
man i love this is the kind of [ __ ] like
i just love
just because it's it's what i call
you call it science 2.0 right i call it
i hate it
i hate i mean i say i hate calling i
call it gnosis which is like that's
better
that's kind of that's thank thank you
it's worth it i i i
geek out and call it like health 3.0
which is
this idea that it's it's the science is
there
we're evidence empowered but then you
have this relationship with a patient
that has these currently intangible
because we don't have
inner subjective ways to measure these
things easily
give that relationship and that hope
streams and fears of the patient that if
you know it and you form a therapeutic
alliance which emerges some state that
we don't understand
that we call the mind-body connection
because we we're we're
you know basically monkeys flapping our
meat holes what do you mean when you say
therapeutic alliance
what do you mean explain that please so
a therapeutic alliance
everybody a lot of people have had this
experience where look i'm having this
suffering i'm having this
issue i'm having this mental thing i'm
having a physical thing whatever it is
i think they're all the same thing
honestly when i find someone
a healthcare professional who
sits with me feels connected to my
suffering
understands what i'm trying to say
witnesses my suffering
it almost doesn't matter what else they
do that alliance that we formed this
inner subjective we
space emerges a kind of healing for lack
of a you know it's a very woo-woo
to talk about and anyone who's practiced
medicine
knows this to be true anyone who's been
a patient and has experienced it
they may not know it because they may
still have this expectation well but he
also gave me an aspirin or gave me an
antibiotic and i got better or maybe
they gave me an antidepressant
what what what they will not and this is
why if you read reviews of docs online
what they do doesn't matter it's how
they did it
that's fascinating it has to do with
also complaints doctors who
people dislike get complained against at
a far
disproportionate rate than doctors that
they do like that gave them
mistreatments absolutely and you this is
interesting
because doctors who get those complaints
and again i'm
deeply connected in the healthcare
community right there's like three
million people who
who follow across platforms and most of
them are healthcare professionals and i
get messages
they are wounded deeply
when they get a complaint that says hey
i don't like the way this guy treated me
or the way that they behaved or the way
their staff was
because they'll say i did all the
scientific stuff i'm more evidence-based
than the doctor that they wrote a good
review for
i'm doing things i'm trying not to harm
the patient so on they have these
expectations they want antibiotics for a
cold
they want narcotics for pain i know
that's harmful and so they were mad at
me
but what's missed there and that's
normal that's defensive
sort of posturing what's missed there is
that well so what
failed in the therapeutic alliance that
we're not
able to let ourselves see because it's
hurtful to us because we realize
oh there's something about me here that
is actually and
why are they defensive in the first
place because they know underlying it is
this the kind of unworthiness that many
of us have you know as type a's
so it is a dynamic and um
is that something taught what i mean by
no what i mean is in school do they
teach you how to be
personable or amiable they they
they give you lip service to the bedside
manner and the patient relationship
and they you know they do this kind of
thing but they've not figured out how to
teach it
the way that we learn it is by example
from whoever our attending physicians
are
so what i would try to do is try to
emulate doctors that i knew
were really good at that and so here's a
but but if you have bad mentors or bad
examples which is rampant
because we just recapitulate our own
training
um and a lot of the older doctors are
injured by their training like the
training used to be just absolutely even
more brutal than it is now but
they're injured by it injured meaning
psychically injured by it
so you know it used to be very common
you would just be in the hospital for 36
hours or longer
working the whole time constantly shamed
by yourself
yeah so they then recapitulate this
cycle
uh and and so you watch it and and then
of course it bleeds into patient care
because you've been trained to be a
psychopath and
now you're asked to be compassionate or
empathetic right which i don't conflate
by the way compassion and empathy which
we can talk about
they're quite different and actually one
is harmful one is actually beneficial
but um so we're not really trained that
we watch
doctors doing it now one one thing i
remember seeing for example is is
you know dr norm risk who was the head
of icu when i was there training at
stanford as a resident
he would tell patients at the in the icu
sickest of the sick
patients that we all knew like us
residents were like why are we still
in ventilating this patient on tons of
agents to keep their blood pressure up
giving them all these antibiotics
millions of dollars of care
patients unconscious never going to make
it family is not
clear that this is the end and why are
we doing this this is a kind of injury
to us because we're forced to be
complicit in a torture
because nobody is going to openly say
what's absolutely true which is we're
not helping this patient so what norm
risk would do is he would call a family
meeting with all of us we'd sit there
with the family
he would hold the hand of the person he
was talking to as the authority figure
with the gray hair
and he would say you know there comes a
point where
we are doing things to your husband
instead of for your husband and i think
we
are past that point now and he would
then engage in
you know whatever anger or denial or
bargaining or anything that came out
and by watching that by absorbing that
you
model you imprint on that like a little
duckling and when you talk to patients
that same sort of language emerges so
that's that's a lot of how the
apprenticeship of medicine
training works now you can imagine
though if you don't have a norm risk
and you have you know bobby mcbobby from
the community who's been
injured by their own training and
doesn't is burned out and
you they're going to model that to you
and and honestly by the end of my full
academic career
as a hospital doc i was modeling bad
behavior to residents because i was
pretty burned out so you know it took
stepping away to regain
the connection to actual compassion
because empathy wasn't working his
empathy will will kind of burn you out
because empathy is feeling someone else
yeah so and
let's be very precise so affective
empathy is feeling someone else's
suffering
as your own so taking that suffering and
really inhabiting it
and then acting from the feeling of
suffering not so much for love of the
patient
but acting for relief of that suffering
oh i know what it's like to
you know withdraw from narcotics maybe
the best thing to do is just
give them a little bit of morphine to
calm them down because man i've been
through that myself you're watching this
channel because you're interested in
theoretical physics
consciousness and the ostensible
connection between the two what's
required to follow some of these
arguments is
facility with mathematics as well as
discernment of the underlying physical
laws and
you may think that this is beyond you
but that's false brilliance provides
pelucid explanations of abstruse
phenomenon such as
quantum computing general relativity and
even group theory when you hear that the
standard model is based on u1 cross su 2
cross su 3
that's group theory for example now this
isn't just for neophytes either
for example i have a degree in math and
physics and i still found
some of the intuitions given in these
lessons to vastly aid my penetration
into these subjects for example
electricity and magnetism sign up today
at brilliant.org
tow that is t-o-e for free you'll also
get 20
off the annual premium subscription try
four of the lessons at least don't
stop before four and i think you'll be
greatly surprised at the
ease at which you comprehend subjects
you previously had trouble grocking
links are in the description i have a
quick question about morphine while
we're on this
i know we're on a great thread morphine
apparently doesn't cross the blood-brain
barrier
is that correct you actually don't know
the answer to that
okay don't know the answer that yeah
okay well as far as i know heroin does
and the heroin becomes morphine in the
brain and that's one of the reasons
heroin is more potent than morphine
i don't know if this is true so most of
them are processed in the liver
to turn into morphine compounds that are
then active
okay well something i was wondering is
why is it that morphine feels good
when it seems to give you a slight high
if it doesn't cross the blood-brain
barriers that simply because of the
connection between
mind and body well okay so first i'd
have to confirm that that's
true that it doesn't have a central
effect because i think it does
i know it has you know direct central
spinal effect
there are opioid mu receptors throughout
the nervous system i don't
know it could be just because i haven't
looked at this in a long time but the
euphoric
sense which isn't it's actually
different for different types of opioids
and partially it's how they're
metabolized
and a pain special should be able to
speak to this more cogently
but but we found patients would request
specific narcotics because they provided
a a euphoria like say demerol
dilaudid had much more euphoria than
just iv
morphine or heaven forbid uh you know
coding which you know i think 10 or 20
of caucasians don't even process
correctly so they don't get any
experience from it um sorry you're
saying you don't want to give people
coding
no no people don't want it because it
doesn't give you that
that euphoria um and so so we always
knew like patients will request a
certain hierarchy of narcotics in fact
they will even tell you i'm someone
who's dependent on narcotics
and we you know we can use this term
addiction they may come to the emergency
department with a complaint and say okay
i'm allergic to morphine
i'm allergic to codeine i'm allergic to
all these aspirin and
tylenol derivatives the only thing that
helps me starts with a d
i don't remember the name d d d and
you're like demeral
yeah that's it or dilaudid oh yeah
so there's definitely a hierarchy of
narcotics so they all have slightly
different
experiences now some of that is
expectation so we talked about mind body
some of that is expectation
one interesting thing is the placebo
effect which
nobody really understands there's a guy
at harvard who studies it and some
others that study it but
it's been getting stronger over time
over the decades now why is that
is it because people especially
americans expect our medicines to work
more than they did in the old days and
it's gotten so bad
kurt that now apparently if you redid
the same studies that showed that
certain antidepressants ssris
actually work they would no longer work
against placebo
because the placebo has gotten so
powerful so it tells you again like how
much of this is mined
the we space the therapeutic alliance
all of that that emerges health 3.0
where you have the science component of
the stuff that you can reduce
to the objective and then there's the
internal experience not just of i
internal but of we the inner subjective
experience which is
again it's an internal state
externalized between two people and we
use
language as a way to bridge it because
there's no way to know your internal
state unless you tell me
which is why it's so uncomfortable to
describe a non-dual experience
because it's the words just fail and
then you're just like you think i'm
crazy
that's what it feels like sometimes
remember how i mentioned that
i think theories of everything free will
consciousness and god are intimately
tied
i also think that the placebo effect and
self-fulfilling
prophecies are in there somewhere
i'm i may be writing a a book on
the placebo effect because there's
well it's just the more you think about
it the more it boggles the mind
as for the antidepressant not performing
as well why
would that be the case unless an
antidepressant is harming you because
wouldn't the antidepressant be raised at
the same level as placebo
yeah yeah so sorry i should be very
specific if you did
that trial uh um
exactly back then using the level of
placebo that
is now you know the efficacy of placebo
now it would fail
but what would probably happen now is
both would rise and the question is
would the uh active ingredient rise more
than placebo
and still be statistically significant
we don't know because i don't think the
trial has been done
but it is quite interesting and you're
on to something with that and
and by the way tying that back into what
your whole
you know this you know gnosis that
you're talking
about yeah yeah yeah you know
uh daniel schmacktenberger who i think
you know um
and i were talking and he shared a piece
of writing that he wrote he
he looks at it this way he calls it the
dance of
the dao with the ten thousand things
and that's a very poetic way of saying
the absolute which was whatever is
fundamental reality whether it's
emptiness or awareness or whatever you
want to call it
dances with manifestation which is the
stuff we can measure and quantify and
use our typical science on
in an intimate and inseparable way
that's
beautiful and complex when i think of
human organisms
i think of what um what federico fajine
who i've had on my show
talks about he's he's he's a like
someone who's funded some of don
hoffman's work
he is a physicist italian guy who
invented the
or co-invented the co-developed the
first commercial microprocessor with
intel
in the 70s and since has worked on ai
and stuff and
he wrote a book about this he feels that
you know humans are these quantum
classical hybrid systems
where you you know when he uses quantum
he's talking about this indeterminate
space where free will may emerge from
nothing and and that may be
another for this kind of substance of
reality and then it manifests
in this very classical deterministic way
in the form of the body in the body like
a human cell is a quantum classical
hybrid
so you have this really kind of
indeterminate free will
generating complexity of of is-ness and
then you have
the mechanistic stuff we can measure and
quantify and they're not two
so i think that's an interesting way to
look at that wait we said they're not
two
not two meaning they're not separate
they're
intertwined at the human level or in
reality
in in so in other words the way he
describes it as a metaphor is
the human body is like the interface in
a virtual reality
the user of the virtual reality is in
the quantum realm and is pure
free will decision making and then it
interfaces with
this realm in an absolutely
seamless way where you would never know
that this is an avatar but it and again
but again
it's all made out of awareness
ultimately is his
posit it's all still one substance but
it just appears in this way
and mechanistically it functions like
this where the avatar
and our decision making and
another way to think about this is when
you're in a flow state or you're in an
authentic conversation like we're having
a pretty authentic conversation right
now
where is any of this coming from the
discussion we're having the words that
we're speaking
it comes from emptiness it comes from
something that we can't
point back from darkness really and
federico's argument is that
it comes from the free will decisions
that are in that
realm rather than right or not who knows
right it's a typical
difficult thing to test this is why when
people say free will exist or free will
doesn't exist i'm always skeptical
because it's
it's absolutely not obvious there are
reasons to believe it
in both directions and then you
mentioned also sam harris is someone
that makes no ontological claims but he
also said that free will doesn't exist
that's an ontological claim
and he also said that god doesn't exist
which is an ontological claim of course
you have to define god
yeah i find um sam is an interesting
character so
he just as my own journey you know i was
a pretty hardcore science-based atheist
reductionist
anything i'm saying now i would have
struck myself as insane
and probably that i've been smoking
something and not a good idea
isn't that fascinating huh isn't it and
uh and that would have been
that would have been eight years ago
that i would told you that now
what's interesting about sam is he was
my gateway drug to spirituality
so i read his atheist works you know uh
letters to a christian nation
and you know i forget what the other one
was and
um was enamored with the new atheists
and these guys and i'm like these guys
are speaking truth man religion's
[ __ ] and all that
then i read you know waking up a guide
to spirituality without religion
and i was like wait sam is yearning
deeply for the same mythos the same
fundamental sense of business meaning
purpose whatever it is that everyone is
religious is
he's just found a different angle on it
and that's when i started meditating and
exploring that path
but he he made it okay to do that now
now i listen to him and i'm like oh man
he's pretty stubborn about a lot of
stuff
like you're right he makes ontological
claims about free will and god and so on
and
and you know i heard his conversation
with rupert spyro which was kind of
painful to listen to because they were
just going at it like
is materialism real or is it all
consciousness and how can you say that
and so on and i'm like
you know you've got rupert here probably
it's a good idea to talk about
you know non-dual experience but
but it was a good conversation because
you could really dig into it he asked
one sam asked one question of rupert
that i thought was fascinating
that was what happens under anesthesia
have you ever had general anesthesia and
i have and
my experience of general anesthesia was
this count down from 10
10 9 8
where am i i'm here awake
in post-op recovery there was an
absolute slice of reality
removed and it didn't have the sense of
continuity
that you have when you go to sleep
so when you sleep there's still a sense
that oh how'd you sleep pretty good
how'd you know that
because there's like a sense of being
that occurs when you're asleep
maybe it's not just dreaming i think
even in deep sleep
but this was different this was like
lights out lights on
and it made me question well maybe
consciousness
is purely a brain-based material thing
because if you give it certain chemicals
it's gone gone in a way that i felt like
i was annihilated like that must be what
death is like
complete non-being and so sam posed the
question to rupert
and they got derailed before rupert
could answer
um because the you know you and i can
tease this out intellectually well
is it just that memory formation is gone
and therefore you can't remember
anything about it
and so therefore you're still aware at
some level but you're not forming
memories and many have posited this
including
those who have experiences of anesthesia
awareness where they remember being
you know being cut on and so on can i
answer what i think rupert may say
sure did you experience non-experience
yeah that's exactly what he might say
and he
so just because you didn't feel a level
of continuity you still experienced you
were only awake you were only
experiencing what you experienced
and to at that level there was
there's continuity between experience i
i i think you nailed it i think and
what's interesting though so
my mind told a story after the fact of
what that experience was it constructed
a reality
to fit you know because i'd never
experienced that i was like what
this is crazy and um and
and so after the fact it was like well
maybe i was maybe consciousness turned
off or maybe i wasn't forming memories
and maybe
and it stuck with me like oh that was
the one experience i had of
you know propofol just you're out were
you in the mouth
afterward what's that were you affable
afterward
so this congenial this here's something
interesting that i found out after the
fact so propofol
tends to do that people wake up they
don't remember and they're really
amorous with the nurses and
you know like hey baby you know and the
thing is my surgery was a penis
reduction surgery
so it's something that most men you know
dream of and i just had to do it out of
necessity
so so so the thing was i had
i had the sense looking at the nurse
afterwards that i'd been yapping
and i didn't ask her but i sensed that
was the case now if that were true
then any experience i had afterwards of
discontinuity
has no relevance to reality because i
was awakened talking
right and a lot of people who've had
propofol will say the same thing they'll
have absolutely no memory of that it's
an amnestic so you just
memory's gone right so re actually
rethinking about this because i hadn't
thought about it
you know you've prompted me to think
about this which you seem to freaking do
in your interviews so many of your
guests go you know i've never thought of
it this way i've actually never thought
of it this way
until kurt said something that prompted
me that's one of your true gifts man
so think about it now again i'm like
probably my assessment of it is not
correct but that was something that sam
had challenged uh rupert on and then
they'd kind of gone off the rails
a little bit after that i remember being
under anesthesia i remember waking up
and just telling the person next to his
wisdom teeth telling the person next to
me
it's great you're going to be fine i
just love
reassuring this person but i don't think
i was funny
i think that was it and then i just
remember being wobbly toward the car
okay getting back to non-dualism i have
some questions for you if you don't mind
yeah is the claim that
is that what's fundamental what's
indispensable primitive and so on
this this realm of undifferentiatedness
now i'm i can't claim to be expert or
stable in this
but
try to imagine and this is not
imaginable but it you can kind of
glance at it imagine that there's
nothing but that even nothing is not the
right descriptor because that implies
that there
is a thing that you're comparing it to
it's almost just
a pure potentiality a pure
okay okay well if it's potential to me
that means that there's a pluristic
notion it's not non-dual
because there's multiple within a
potential you could be many
uh but but uh how do i say this
um that potentiality
by its nature arises
um phenomena that
that are in themselves made of nothing
it's almost like you know rupert's
analogy of
the the film on a the film projector
putting light on a screen if the screen
was this empty potential
you know the light dances on it but it's
not substantial in itself
it's it's it's a um
it's a manifestation that this thing
just does it's like
a primitive urge to just manifest and
even what i'm saying
sounds crazy but that's what it
kind of feels like when you glance on
that and there are those who've
really gone deep into that experience my
friend angelo would describe it as
it's the experience of everything
happening like a foaming
gel like phenomenon are just happening
color shape sounds
out of even to call it nothing is saying
too much
it's interesting to call it nothing is
saying too much he's saying to call it
nothing and he'll say this he goes you
call it nothing and you're already doing
it a disservice it's not that it's
it it in this it it foams this reality
that is entirely empty of substance
and that then foams into the same no
thing
that it came from and that's happening
every iota of the now
and that's reality and he says one other
thing that he says at the very
end of this sort of journey is that the
one thing you realize that's very
destabilizing to people who when you
tell it to them is
there's no way that things actually are
and even that statement
makes no sense to the to the rational
mind but he says that is the truth
it's just happening by itself and
even that is like and now i'm trying to
describe how he would describe it and i
can't
and uh it's really fascinating and you
wonder if he's in any way barking up the
right tree
that the true nature of reality could be
even more and
wonderful and i said well isn't that
nihilism isn't that
my next point it sounds like a pretext
to nihilism
right it sounds like well that's the
worst thing i've ever heard and actually
as the human mind
reads it in his book on the stages of
awakening
he says listen guys don't read this if
you're easily triggered because this is
going to trigger some feelings for you
and all i'm going to tell you is it's
okay the punch line is everything's
better than okay it's beyond okay and
you're like what the hell do you mean by
that
and you read it and you just want to
throw the book in the trash you're like
i'm sorry
the punch line is everything's nothing
and it's coming into nothing and there's
no way things
are what the hell that sounds like the
worst kind of nihilism
it defeats any human impulse to even be
compassionate like why
and what he will say is trust me
when you experience it you will
you will know that it is beyond okay it
is actually
the best news you could ever imagine and
he says you can't describe
that in words it's just everything
happens perfectly as it should
and that means that even suffering even
the experience of suffering
is exactly in its right place at its
right time and there's
no you to fret about it but it doesn't
mean you don't
feel it intensely and that you can't
experience life in the relative
in a in a profound way that you can bear
the kind of suffering that you would
never have beard
feeling you're a this and again that
sounds crazy
he says until you experience it what i'm
wondering is
you just mentioned while we're talking
about nihilism
why isn't where in that is
the statement that promulgating infinite
suffering or
or a large amount of suffering wrong
so why why can i not run amok
and murder and rape and pillage and so
on yeah it's all
nothing it's all okay where's the moral
compass
like where where's the directive when we
had god we could say
there's a judgment here there's a
morality that's set
out in the ten commandments and so on
thou shalt not
where is the morality in an emptiness
that manifests reality
only in the present moment with no
future or past and no self
what's to keep you from running amok or
what's to say
that you shouldn't what's to say that
you shouldn't well
here is what they would say
and again take it with what what you
will
when you've had that experience where
you act from that space
there is no desire to do anything
to another manifestation of this
because if you are doing it it's all one
thing so
what's even the point of hurting someone
and i had one person who
was wide awake who had this experience
to an extreme realization who i've
spoken with
to the point where just talking to him
will put you in the in a state
and he was the one who pointed me to
that suta that says in the scene will be
merely
what is seen and when he did that with
me i had the experience
that was the guy who was 24 when he had
that experience
different guy so this is this is a guy
who's an electrician
who had an awakening in recovery
for alcohol you know in his early 30s
family and had a profound awakening and
since has
further realized you know further
stabilized his realization and
and was pointed to me by another person
and and uh what he says is because i
asked him this exactly this i said well
what you're describing to me now because
he'll just talk he will
try to point for you know an hour
straight and i'll sit on the phone
just being pointed to trying not to
intellectualize too much but
you can't help it so i say what's to
stop you from being a complete [ __ ]
because it sounds to me that you still
have two daughters that you deeply love
and a wife that you deeply love and you
continue to do your job as an
electrician and
yet you're telling me the nature of
reality is this and by the way he points
to exactly the same thing that angelo
pointed to
and so what's the deal and he goes he
goes bro
i just got to tell you when you
experience this you have no like i will
not step on an ant if i can avoid it i
will not
harm anything i will go out of my way i
hate cockroaches i now
pick them up with a thing and throw them
outside because
hurting another thing it feels like i'm
hurting myself
and i and i i couldn't comprehend that
even intellectually i still with there's
no self who are you hurting
but he said they're just it's just that
way
now that then you have to juxtapose with
people who
apparently have had quite profound
awakenings who behave in
reprehensible ways you know um
the andrew cohens and certain zen
masters and so on who
you know sexually taken advantage of
their students and
have never done the work on themselves
they've like spiritually bypassed
all their own baggage and that baggage
still comes out unconsciously or
consciously and they behave in
what we would classify as reprehensible
ways so
you know i i don't know the answer
okay so i understand if you were to
experience that you get to a place where
you would no longer act in a
manner that promulgates suffering but
what's to say that
those who are currently promulgating
suffering
are wrong to do so yeah
they they aren't from this viewpoint
they're just right so it doesn't so this
sounds like so this is nihilism then no
so again i guess it depends on how
you're talking about nihilism but but
the idea that
you would you'd be compelled not to
generate suffering
so what you exude in the in the world
would be something that
actually reduces suffering but you could
look at suffering
and what angela describes to me is he
says when he sees suffering he feels it
intensely and purely
but without self he feels it and there
is
an urge arises to do something about it
you don't
want to tolerate suffering and he told
me the story actually about
i can't repeat the story but it was
about standing up for somebody
in a very difficult situation where he
had to intervene
and this is as a fully awake person so
it's interesting and again not being in
that state i can't speak
from that state but the sense i get is
it is okay now
one thing i want to clarify that i said
about these gurus who go around um
yeah i think this is a very important
thing that angelo pointed out to me and
i think it's true
from my own limited experience
the the ego mind in other words our mind
our structures of conditioning and so on
it does not take waking up to this
lightly
it doesn't take it sitting down it even
after awakenings
people then have to contend with strong
unconscious feelings you know what
young would call the shadow and all of
this those arise
and in fact they're felt you can't avoid
them now because the
the mechanisms of thought projection to
get out of feeling difficult emotions
and
repressed memory and so on that that
becomes untenable it becomes
uncomfortable for you so
you have to face this but some sometimes
and more often than not the ego
reasserts itself and
co-ops the story of awakening to i am
the awakened one
who now is the guru who now has power
who now unconsciously is getting
validation from the students
who now is going to fulfill some of
these unconscious desires for worthiness
by having sex with a student or whatever
it is
so i think that's true and angela's
pointed out to me said even some of the
biggest teachers that you see on youtube
they have signs of this kind of ego
thing everybody does because
that's just we're so conditioned as
humans it's it's very difficult to
transcend it entirely
and still live in the relative world so
you know he says you know even when you
start spiritual pursuits the ego sitting
there in a hammock sipping a mojito
going oh you want to do spirituality i
got you i've been doing this for
thousands of years i'll even help you
and it kind of co-opts the story and i
i'm actually guilty of that too even
telling the story from a position of ego
feels
a little creepy right what would he say
what was this person's name again
angelo delulo i've done a few shows with
him i can link you up with him sure
angela would what would angelo
in order to stop a larger amount of
suffering
commit himself to a smaller amount of
suffering so for example
you hit the child in order to stop them
from
jumping down a stairwell or
you execute someone if they said
as soon as i'm out of this prison even
within the prison i'm going to
harm and torture and maim so is he for
what would he do in that situation or
just let's imagine a fight is about to
break out and the only way
the only way to stop this person as far
as he can conceive
the only way is to knock this person on
their head creating a minor amount of
suffering in order to save a larger
amount what would he do
so i can't speak to what he would do i
can only give an example of what he has
done
and told me and that was in the process
of standing up for this person who was
much lower in a medical hierarchy
he had to tell some very difficult and
painful truths to another person
standing up and that
caused intense unpleasantness in the now
moment that it was happening and that's
how it was described to me
and so in a way it generated suffering
then and there
for the the object i don't know if it
generated suffering for
angelo i can't speak to that but it was
clear that it did
but the longer term consequence was a
relief of suffering and a changing of
behavior and so on
so it's really it's really tough to say
what he would do but
i think that that that's kind of how i
think about it and again i i you know
nobody's
i think our our humanness our ego mind
interposes and i want to read one
comment here in the thread on facebook
laura ann hartman says spiritual
bypasses
are toxic familiar with that term kurt
spiritual bypass
okay so this is what that means and it
points to this
spiritual bypass is where you wake up
spiritually in other words you're like
oh everything's one we're all
consciousness or whatever there's no
self
and you know i'm here now there's only
the now but you
never you use that to bypass all the
baggage
that you've been carrying around all
your neuroses and unconscious
uh issues and psychological baggage and
so you feel like you're very awake but
in reality you're acting in the world
and people will tell you you're kind of
a bigger [ __ ] than you ever were
since you had this enlightenment
experience and
some people call that zen stink it's
like another another term for it like
you walk around like
you're this thing and and that's a real
phenomenon i think is
is people want to escape their pain by
bypassing ever addressing it now angelo
in his book
that he talked about on the show called
awake it's your turn it's like a
self-published thing it's on amazon
he has a whole chapter on like no you've
got to go then and dive
into your emotional emotional state and
feel what you're repressing and look at
thought
understand how thought works and it
creates a sense of identity looking at
the structures of self
as they create themselves is the only
way to understand
how your mind's actually working and
then be liberated from the suffering
component
and one thing i'll say is one thing that
i have gotten the capacity to do through
practicing this
is when i'm in a state of extreme
suffering which happens
i will simply the something in my mind
triggers to remember oh
look what's happening and just watch
your mind for a second
and i'll go all right all right all
right oh man okay
feeling this here thoughts racing you
know
want to cry just really stressed
and and then just take a breath and feel
the
the presence just the present moment and
man dude
it is like it's like someone took
360 joules of electricity and
defibrillated your suffering right there
it doesn't mean it goes away but it
resets from a framework
where within just a few minutes it's
dissipated
enough that you're no longer suffering
like that and i would have thought i was
crazy if i had heard myself say what i
just said even like you know five years
ago
but it's absolutely in our power so the
question is whatever the ontological
metaphysics behind it is there may be
even simple tools here that
are practicable and it's not straight
meditation right because you said
something that i thought was
[ __ ] spot on early in our
conversation man meditation does not
work for me it may work for others it
doesn't work for me for this kind of
thought storm and thing
i agree like this idea that oh suddenly
you're gonna focus on your breath
when the thoughts are coming you know
maybe those
should just trigger the more meta
awareness of hey this is thoughtstorm
that's not a breath-based vipassana
meditation you know
it's a different type of mindfulness but
it's not a class what we would
classically call meditation although
some would argue it's a type of
meditation
who are some of these people i should
speak to angelo's one of them
if you talk to angela you'd have a great
conversation it would be a way better
conversation than i've ever had with him
because you're so
uh good at that so angela delulo um
honestly there are people that are more
in the rupert spyra spectrum
on youtube that i don't think you would
add a lot
to the conversation talking with them
beyond what you did with rupert
but if you talk to angelo uh
you'd get a totally different angle like
a totally different angle
on this and i think i would i would pay
to see it
honestly um someone keeps calling me the
nerd that
sits at the front of the class who asks
questions it's the best
you're you're my hero dude you're you're
the you i i've been trying to formulate
you brother because
it's very rare that i'll watch somebody
on youtube and be and
and be simultaneously furious that that
i can't do that and at the same time
just like
jaw drops in awe and and there's
something in your
being something in how you your mix of
intellectualization which is crucial to
getting at understanding and openness
like
beginner's mind uh you know with rupert
he's he was
forced to talk about non-duality in ways
that i don't think he's probably
ever had to do it which is great
especially for a teacher where you're in
these patterns of like let me explain it
the way i know it's supposed to be
explained
and then along comes kurt and he's like
[ __ ] i don't
here's what about this and and rupert's
just like
uh okay let me think about that or not
think about that let me make myself
present and have this stuff arise
it was awesome to watch man it was
really really really compelling
i think it comes from personal
humiliation
i've been humiliated by
these like you mentioned you used to be
a staunched atheist materialist
for let's say 15 years at least
so same with me i'm not saying that i'm
not that but i'm
sorry i'm not that but i'm not the
opposite
and right there's so many experiences in
my life where i thought for
sure this is the case and then it's not
and it's come to the point where now
the more i trust my own instincts the
more i see actually i have questions
every single and everywhere
so here's an example that's near and
dear to you
with regard to the whole issue of
societal mistrust of science i
i understand it i see that
like i understand it on one level
there's some
there's some amount of following that
has to occur
because not everyone can do their own
research
so some and society is based on trust
but then at the same time for some
tenants bruited by the
institutions let's say and i'm not using
i'm not that's not square quotes i'm
just
quoting okay institutions that
like for example masks were good now
more masks were bad
then masks were good and so on that
that they raised my eyebrow when they
before wooden i was a wholehearted
truster of whatever
the scientific quote-unquote community
says
and now i just i want to look at the
research and i understand that
i don't want people to take away from
this
a justification for their own mistrust
because that's i see the same happening
on the one end that's saying no trust
whatever fauci is saying or whatever
whoever is saying
you know that's a hot topic right now on
the one end you have people who are
with a limpet characteristic adhering to
that but then at the other end
you have people who are completely
anti-vaccine
saying that they're anti-trust of
science but then if
if a scientific article came out saying
oh it turns out that the cove vaccines
were horrible you'd see the anti-vaxxers
jump on that and say yes you see but i
thought you mistrusted science why don't
you mistrust that as well
like you should be doubting everywhere
so for me i'm i'm doubting everywhere
and even my brother who is a professor
of statistics
technically of finance statistical
finance
he said he it would take him a week to
go through any meta-analysis
because it's not trivial at all even for
a professor of statistics
that's another reason why i try to do as
much research as i can because i'm
i want to understand so when someone
makes a claim like
vaccines are good or vaccines are bad
and by the way zubin
there's so many oh okay you're getting
me
a bit excited now man i like where
you're going brother intrude into my
sleep
but something i dislike is
it's not just it's the labeling of
people who mistrust
science as they see them as just trump
supporters irrational trump supporters
and because one side hates trump so much
and trump has been attached to
anti-science then they view anyone who
is critical of whatever epilogue is
given by
the institutions quote unquote as trump
supporters who are racists and bigots
and anti-intellectual and people who are
intellectual one of the worst
their worst fears is not being
irrational it's being seen as being
irrational so they want to be on the
side of what's intellectual
and i think there's so much hidden
motivation behind people to believe what
they believe
that it takes so much self-investigation
you think
that you believe in vaccines or
anti-vaccines because you're on the side
of the truth
but you you peel away and you realize
there's something more
dark underneath man
uh what what you just unleashed is the
pandora's box that's kind of the central
premise of our platform during the
pandemic which is
you do have to question everything you
do at the same time it's balancing with
relying on expertise that you don't have
to parse data that you can't parse
because either you don't have the time
because it's impossible to do it all
or you don't have the expertise and then
filtering through
the lens of the authorities have gotten
a lot of [ __ ] wrong
we've been there's a huge profit motive
a lot of our regulatory agencies are
uh are captured by the same entities
they're supposed to regulate
witness the alzheimer's drug at a helm
and that the nonsense there that would
bankrupt the u.s
economy uh the the u.s medicare if we
actually
approved it and they approved it despite
two studies showing it really doesn't
work
um this this kind of questioning
what it's what i call on our show the
alt middle so it's this new like
stance and it's something that we've
kind of we've made t-shirts with
because we're we're idiots so the alt
middle is a radical position
that you inhabit that says okay
forget about politics and all that this
is about opening your mind
to different ideas without judging
people who hold opposing ideas as evil
so in other words
hearing everything seeing everything as
maybe having some truth but being
partial
and then assuming good intent and having
discourse
well heaven forbid there's nothing in
social media that rewards that
with the exception of what i found
paying subscriber platforms like
locals facebook youtube where people pay
five bucks a month to congregate and
have
speaking of man that was perfectly timed
someone just gave ten dollars
look at that as soon as you said that
what's it done
andrew dunbar says i dozed off shortly
after z dog introduced the guest
i woke up about 10 minutes ago with no
clue what was going on and thought yes
yes
this is what happens when a society
legalizes marijuana
i don't know if you're talking about you
andrew having smoked a little too much
or us either way so so back to this
middle idea
um and thank you for the support andrew
the the you can create
environments you can model environments
where the pursuit of knowledge
understanding being civil to each other
that sort of thing
actually actually is
the default so i was recently on the
rebel wisdom podcast with
david fuller and we talked about this
trying to find
sense one of your big concerns is how do
you make sense how do you make sense
when the
the epistemic commons like our our
common knowledge sources are gone
there's no more walter cronkite there's
no more single source of truth
it's now a bunch of fragments each with
their own ideology
that it's all about signaling like you
said oh as an intellectual i don't even
want to be
perceived as anti-intellectual half the
[ __ ] i told you on this thing
i would never have said three years ago
because
i would have been vilified by like a
david gorsky or someone as full of woo
anti-scientific exactly how i feel you
know what i'm talking about so so
i think this is a fundamental question
and i do think it's going to emerge i
think we have to
those on the leading edge of it which is
like our audience like
your audience my audience they think
like this so let's encourage it
i've gotten to the point now where i
never used to like censor comments on my
on my threads but what i'm finding is
when people behave in ways that are that
are anti-alt-middle so they're
throwing ad hominems they're being very
overtly politically
you know idiotic you know it's like oh
you're a trump supporter because of this
or you're a
radical leftist because of this that's
why i loved your documentary by the way
because you dive into that [ __ ]
in a deep way which was beautiful thank
you i've started going in now
and deleting blocking the people who
make those comments because what they're
there to do
is to signal to their tribe they're not
there to advance
conversation and then what i noticed is
so then you get all kinds of complaints
oh you're
you're stifling free speech it's not
free speech this is the community
i'm trying to com create you can come
here and we're
this is our value is alt middle so if
you behave in that way you can disagree
with me in fact i want you to
but i want you to do it in a way that
assumes i'm not i'm not acting in bad
faith and you're not acting in bad faith
and we're coming to a discourse and it
changes the dynamics then people go to
the video and they see the comments are
much more
constructive even if they disagree then
you stupid bald pharmaceal i'm gonna
tell
you you're paid off by [ __ ] hilarious
i wish bro you know
i have the i'm still on your i'm still
early zubin then
because my i'm of the mind i don't
delete a single comment some people
think i do but youtube's algorithm
actually
filters out quite a few it does yeah and
people think i'm actively deleting i'm
not so my disincentive system is
i read each comment i heart them but if
they're negative toward the guest i
don't
heart them so they can be negative
toward me they can be negative towards
the guesses
guest's theories but not add hominins at
the guests and then
that's the only time i don't hurt them
and i but i don't delete
i actually like what you're doing you
have to
do that that's only because the guest is
like
the guest this is i they're in my home
right there so i'm not going to have
invite them in and have them insulted
people are saying
it's fine totally i'm with you so that's
how i used to be i would only block
people who were being absolutely vicious
to my guest because
it is it's like someone comes a guest in
my home and someone comes and throws
feces at them it's like no that's not
okay they're in my house
but now i if if they what i what i've
decided is
it's an it's if i'm trying to model
behavior
of how we should have discourse why
should my community
be showing the opposite of that behavior
now now again that's not for everyone
and actually david fuller and i
talked about this on on on a discussion
on zoom is like what do you do with this
uh because you don't like a stifle
conversation but at the same time
you you almost want to encourage like
hey i want you to disagree in the
comments but do it in a way that's civil
and then the comments fill up with
people who disagree that's great
instead of bald pharma clown which hey i
love that stuff because it juices
youtube's algorithms
because when youtube sees controversy it
serves it out but
is that good for like building an alt
middle mindset no
i don't like snarky comments either or
people who ask
questions but they are asking it from an
antagonistic point of view
where they just want to well technically
it's called trolling or make baits
i have a discord and so there's
moderation there but not by me because i
cannot take part in the moderation
i i don't want to censor because
i i don't i know you mentioned the term
good faith and good intentions
i actually i'm on the opposite end
i don't care if someone has bad
intentions the reason is that i have bad
intentions
and the more i examine my good
intentions the more i realize that
they're bad
so i don't care if someone has bad
intentions i also don't care if
someone's biased
the reason is that for someone to be
biased sometimes they can get to an
argument a place that
you have to be motivated in order to get
there and they can
tell you they can come up with a to a
truth that you would have
never found because you're not going to
expend the energy because you're not
tied to that
particular philosophy or whatever it may
be so i actually
don't mind speaking to someone who's
biased because they will have the most
strengthened
art the most strengthened arguments for
their position because they're
so what they're so
devoted to it oh i agree a thousand
percent we're all biased
so the question is you can be biased and
come and make these really intense
arguments i want that
what i don't want is just straight ad
hominem or like you said the kind of
trolling grandstanding like you know if
i have a guest and they're just making
these comments that are vicious and
there's just no no i used to just let it
all go because also i didn't have the
capacity right so
it's just but my assistant helps me now
we have these sort of rules of how to do
it
but because facebook got to the point
where my audience was asking me to
moderate comments because it was just
full of just the worst conspiracy stuff
just discounting anything i said based
on i'm paid off by some pharma thing
which by the way that's all public
information
i'm a physician the sunshine act forces
any pharma company to disclose what they
pay
unless they're behaving illegally right
yeah and so so i have to say well yeah i
did a couple talks
talking about health 3.0 to
pharmaceutical m
a people the the the medical affairs
people
who do the research and there it is on
the site so
how am i in pfizer's pocket i really
want
so the key thing is like you know with
vaccines it's so hard to know because
you can get a really smart person online
who maybe even be a
virologist like gert vondenbush give
what sounds like a very compelling
argument for why we're really harming
people
and you and i maybe maybe even talked
about this uh
saying this here's here's the reasons i
think this is a terrible idea we
shouldn't be doing mass vaccination
during a pandemic
here are the reasons why we're going to
generate mutant strains that are that
are
resistant to the vaccines but that the
immune memory is going to prevent us
from being able to fix that
um even with with boosters and so on so
it sounds very compelling you dig into
it and you you see
okay there's some flaws here in the
thinking actually some of the science
isn't quite right and oh he's actually
got his own thing that he's trying to
develop
that has to do with natural killer
killer cells so
i'm like so on your level not with
respect to
disbelieving gert or or discounting him
in any way but
with regard to hearing the opposition
what i want with my channel i wanted to
get you or someone else
who's an expert in virology to speak
with gert or someone else
and hammer it out but what i don't like
and going back to the mistrust of
science is that
these large agencies and this is not a
right issue
it's not conservative in fact noam
chomsky talked about this in the 70s or
80s
with manufacturing consent they
s the fact that i may be demonetized
for talking about the potential dangers
of vaccines or having a debate
on it i that's why where my eyebrows
raised why are you
why are you squelching the opposition
they've made everything worse right by
doing that that's insane
you have tech oligopolies making
decisions on who can speak that's insane
what we should do now here's the problem
though so how do you make sense in a
world like this
and this is something david and i talked
about david fuller
because even my argument to you like
well i don't want to do a thing with
gert vondenbush because
first of all i'm not a virologist we
need a virologist second of all there's
this idea of false equivalence where by
highlighting a platform that you firmly
think is wrong and harmful potentially
you're giving it more credence now i
think that argument
is no longer valid in this world it's no
longer valid because
they have a platform it's called youtube
they can go and say whatever they like
your job as a scientist or whatever is
to try to promote what you think is
correct and the discourse that leads to
that
so we ought to have virologists going
and talking to the bigger people that
are
that are promulgating these ideas you
know the malones and von
vandenbush and um you know uh uh
pierre cory on ivermectin and these kind
of things go and have the conversation
you know and and i would honestly i
would do it i don't have a problem with
it the thing is
i actually i don't feel worthy to do it
like i i i
know i completely understand i i'm a
communicator i need somebody who studies
this for a living
to go and say okay let's go depth by in
depth by that because i'll be
manipulated like a pierre cory would
have no problem
actually not him because i think i could
i could do it with him i just
i've talked about this publicly before
about ivermectin and why i i think
we need the trials before we can say
anything about it but that all being
said
you need somebody who can really dig in
now the problem is the big virologists
are biased in their own way
so they're like you know part of the
mainstream scientific community they see
this as just an annoyance or a nuisance
they don't realize that these these
folks are influencing a lot of people to
not get vaccinated so if you think the
vaccines are safe and effective
then it's kind of on you to go and
communicate it now paul offit is a big
vaccine guy
mainstream guy come on my show a few
times very rational guy but he is biased
towards vaccines always says what he
does he's a pediatrician and he's
invented the
co-invented the rotavirus vaccine that's
you know saved countless lives around
the world but
he does see it through that lens um
he's written a book on why scientists
are terrible communicators
so what can happen is a not very good
scientist
who has enough of the lingo who's a good
communicator can convince the world of
something that's really a fringe idea
with equal weight or bigger weight than
the mainstream that are terrible
communicators
because they're in the lab all day and
they're a little bit on the spectrum and
they're you know they're who they are
and you know paul in his book actually
wrote a lot of stories about how he
would go on these press things and just
make a fool of himself
because he just first of all i think
scientists overestimate it's like part
of the dunning-kruger
kind of uh curve where it's not that you
you know so little that you don't know
what you don't know that's like
very low understanding you know a lot
but then the the
the logic the um cognitive uh error
there is
you assume everyone else knows at least
as as much as you do
and you operate from that assumption and
it comes off either as condescending or
just
blind to the fact that people need basic
education on this stuff
so it's very complicated and i i
struggle with my own role in this
because
you know when i do a show i'm looking
you can see i've got nice equipment
it's all very polished you know so all
right
you look great brother you know yours is
authentic only guys come on
dude dude but the thing is it's so
polished you shouldn't trust me
you may instinctively not trust me like
i'm looking right at the camera i'm
making eye contact with the audience i'm
speaking without a script
that's a little concerning like to to
people
some people find that very off-putting
because it doesn't
have the you know like if i were just
with my phone i'm like guys let me just
tell you what's going on and i do that
too
i usually do those in lives those will
often engage a lot more
because people's trust mechanism fires
when they feel like they're on a face
time with someone instead of this very
produced thing so
i struggle with that in terms of my own
show it's just i'm a nerd and i like
[ __ ] to look good
and i look like [ __ ] at baseline so
having a nice camera and lighting
uh by the way i got to say this about
your um your documentary
uh better or better left unsaid your
suit that you wore in that
it was tailored like oh wow thank you it
was i
was guess what it was not tailored it
was off the rack
dude he had something like a gl that was
a coincidence
i mean i'm not gay but if i were i'd be
like
me too guys
is it all right i'm going to quickly
mute turn off my mic sorry
mute turn off this for about 10 seconds
to tell my wife that we're just wrapping
up so that she knows
absolutely absolutely want to respect
your time too i'll read some comments
while you're doing that
um tim davis says i wake up
almost every night at 3 a.m did an
experiment with glucose monitor noticed
my glucose levels were clashing
crashing it at the every time every
night diet
at the right time resolved it now it's
only occasional so tim was talking about
like his waking up in the
night of anxiety was doing a
physiological cause another
sorry is it okay if i tell you a bit
about my sleep quickly yeah
please so i've been fasting for the past
some 74 hours or so into a fast
when i fast i tend to not be able to
sleep i also find that my heart races
faster
even if i even if i'm not thinking of
an anxious thought at all my heart just
seems to beat
i don't know if that's correlated with
the fasting or if that's
is it is it a pure water fast that
you're doing well sometimes
yeah i have coffee you have coffee okay
but you're not getting electrolytes
you're not getting anything else
okay so to some extent
the sleep deprivation may just simply be
a hormonal hunger thing
it could also be that the sense of
palpitations the heart kind of racing
that you have
it can sometimes be because your
potassium is a little out of whack
because
just finishing up with iterative like a
zero gatorade well gato yeah gatorade
without any um
and again i'm not an expert in water
fasting so someone like peter attia
who's a friend of mine would be a good
person to talk to
um the the idea that
there's a lot of things in you know in a
72 hour let me see so
you know three days of that you know
human body is pretty resilient you can
do that but there will be these
absolutely about to eat man after this i
told you i'm gonna go into bliss
i i'm gonna eat every i know that i
shouldn't do that after long fast but
that's how i
operate dude that's how that's how we
evolved it's like never happens
i'm wondering is this good for me or is
it bad for me going through it
somewhat like intermittent fasting like
drastic fast overeat
drastic fast i imagine that sorry
no go go ahead go ahead i imagine that
that's plenty of what our ancestors did
though not all the time but for plenty
of the time because you would kill
then so gorge assume assuming you don't
have an eating disorder
that is going to be exacerbated by this
right which is always a caveat
fasting is like it can be wonderful for
people i think it's not anti-physiologic
at all i think there's
plenty of at least reasonable level
evidence that
it's not harmful and it may be helpful
for some people
i myself do one meal a day as my sort of
feeding window thing and that's the only
way at 48 i keep from becoming morbidly
obese because i love food so much
i am the exact same way one meal a day
almost every single day because i cannot
help my i am avaricious
i'm voracious i'm rapacious
you're using some big words that i don't
understand and i'm gonna take that as a
personal
insult all right but i will say this i'm
a fat ass
if left to my own devices i will you're
exactly and by the way when in your in
your in your documentary when you showed
your mom's cooking i was like oh god
my parents are parsy from pune india
and my mom same thing just i just i
could eat that all day
and be like 500 pounds um
it it's so so your sleep and your
fasting they do
interact and some of it is the fact how
often do you do the fasts
once a week i'll fast for 48 hours
this one is 72 hours but it's once a
week about 48 hours
and then how are you one meal a day so
so so anyone who's like oh you fast and
your brain gets foggy i mean you started
out foggy because you were tired and
you've done a bunch of
podcasts but then man once you woke up
it was like oh [ __ ]
so whatever ketones you're burning now
are you energizing me man you energize
me you take
all the credit belongs to you trust me
because i've been speaking to a couple
people today and you should have seen me
just in a torpor
with dude sometimes mental and spiritual
apathy
sometimes when i have an in-person guest
and i'm not feeling it
it's like i'm in a different world like
my mind is somewhere else and i'm like
uh
okay back to this happens early but it's
a really horrible
because it feels terrible well you've
taken your time out for me
and then it's as if i'm not giving you
your best i also
well i also wonder see this is what i
mean when i say constantly question
myself
because how much of my fasting is also
self-sabotage so one
because i'm vain and i want to keep thin
two because i'm
filled with gulosity and i want to eat
three because
it's okay that i fail because i'm
fasting and so therefore
therefore if i'm not up to par i have an
excuse
so that's not consciously there but if i
examine myself i can imagine that that
lurks just
thinly veiled underneath brother
it's like we're cut from the same cloth
man so the the reason i never prep for
interviews very much
is partially so i have plausible
deniability when it sucks
i'm like well you know i just winged it
i you know
i i didn't really do anything so yeah i
mean next time if i
if i did something it would have kicked
ass the mind and a lot of it's
unconscious you can bring it into
consciousness you shine a light on it
but you know i got to say and now the
only thing i'd say is maybe research a
little bit on
your electrolyte situation is there
something you can do within that fast
i'll try that
yeah you know especially potassium and
sodium are often
wasted early on in a fast as you switch
from
burning carbs to burning fat and going
to ketosis
there's a diuretic effect where you do
lose a lot of that so a lot of times in
people talk about the keto flu when
you're first going into ketosis
this idea that people feel really kind
of crummy may maybe partially due to
that aspect of it like atiya and others
have recommended
broths with high sodium and potassium
you can take
you know potassium supplements i don't
know if that's necessary for this
you'd really have to kind of dig into it
a bit because i'm not an expert in it
but those are just stuff
off the top of my head and then man i'm
looking forward to your meal dude
eating after a fast is like oh it's
orgasmic yeah
yeah someone mentioned thc i'm wondering
about
dabbling in some of that that also helps
me sleep thc helps tremendously
but apparently thc while it reduces the
sleep lag like the time it takes to get
to sleep it disrupts your sleep cycle
but cbd
doesn't contribute to sleep lag but it
helps your sleep cycle
yeah that i've i've heard exactly that
and i've experienced that with thc that
you go to sleep fine and then you wake
up with this
you know kind of dysphoric sense in the
middle of the night a few times at least
i do
i know for me for me i wake up in
a bed of mirthful
overjoyed the
jubilance like oh my gosh this feels so
great because i wake up so rested and
even
in the middle of the night if i wake up
i'm like these are the best sheets they
feel like they've been
just washed and it's the queen's sheets
isn't it fascinating how our perception
is so malleable
you know hey one thing kind of just to
tie it and i i i'm by the way just stop
me whenever you need to go because i
know you keep going i'm enjoying this
man i just wanted
let me tell my wife once more i just
want her to know and let me get up don't
get me in trouble bro
or blame it on me
you know let me read a comment real
quick while we're doing this um
i wake up with the munchies says jamie
vance there it is lizette paris is a
supporter says oh i feel like indian
food right now
right so do i we're getting korean food
tonight after the show i'm going with my
family we're going to go to
foster city and get some dope korean
food on facebook samantha
espionage says i'm very open-minded and
will listen to the beliefs of others
even if they contradict my own
i take both into consideration and if
the opposing belief seems more logical
than my own
then i'm not afraid to allow myself to
adopt them so that's what you
consciously think samantha that you're
already ahead of most people
i would advise you to even look
unconsciously and go
what part of me is resisting this what
part of me is triggered by this what
part of me won't
um let go or the malleability of my own
beliefs and it may be that you're
you've already done that right which is
wonderful but many of us haven't
you know my unconscious is very
resistant to a lot of things
and i have to bring that resistance into
conscious awareness you know shine a
light on it you know they say like
sunlight's the best disinfectant it's
the same with consciousness
making something that's automatic
something that's
now aware is is a huge uh asset so what
were we talking about brother we were
talking about um
perception so
the one interesting insight i've had
that may not be an insight so
i rarely ever uh uh use thc anymore when
i was younger it was a different subject
but
now you know occasionally i'll do it as
an experiment into
into consciousness like what what does
this do yeah i'm not a fan of recreation
drug use recreational drug use
it has to be for a particular purpose
like insight into the
into reality or to help you sleep or
whatever maybe therapeutic
therapy yeah some kind of
investigational purpose now right when i
was young it was recreational and that
was not a good idea
so the the the um
what i noticed with that is you know if
hoffman talks about
our perceptual interface our his
interface theory which is
we have a species specific way of seeing
the
social network of consciousness around
us and it and it's evolved to
allow us to reproduce it's it's fitness
payoffs it's not seeing truth
well what drugs do like thc like lsd
whatever
is they take that evolved interface and
they shift it
so lsd may really
just blow it out right it's what you're
saying that
what we see on lsd may be partially what
reality is truly like or distorted
version
no what we're all what i'm what i would
argue is hoffman's argument which is
reality is simply consciousness
interacting with itself and we
see it in a constructed way that
benefits us
as a species to reproduce so we
construct it in a way that allows us to
get food and have mates
now what what the drugs do is they don't
you don't you don't see more reality or
whatever
what you do is you see that same
reality the objective reality which is
this conscious
agent network happening um
manifesting but you see it with a
different interface you might see it
with an interface that
would be evolutionarily advantageous if
x y and z
so what i find with thc this is what i
think is fascinating
you you'll talk to those people right
who are and there's a lot of variation
in our own interfaces people with
synesthesia who you know hear sounds or
see uh sounds things like that or
hoffman gives the example of the
chef who whenever he tastes mint he
feels in his hand a cool column of glass
um those are mutations in our interface
they're changes in our interface that at
some point may become evolutionary
advantageous
and we select for them so what what what
i think is
with thc there are those people who are
like bro i just i'm so anxious at
baseline i can't sleep at baseline i'm
a total [ __ ] like joe rogan will say
this i'm a complete [ __ ] at baseline
i smoke some weed and i'm just a
different person i'm better
i'm calmer i sleep better i could do
this all day every day and still
function perfectly
what i suspect with them is their
baseline interface
is slightly shifted towards the more
paranoid
a little more sensitive a little more
anxious
a little more insomnia a little more
thoughts racing you give them thc it
shifts it back to what you and i would
call
normal or or whoever whoever's in that
normal state
for me as someone who's you know a
little anxious whatever what
what that shift does is it makes me more
paranoid more sensitive
more enjoyable of sensory stimulus so
food touch
sound is unbelievable
but with that comes a sensitivity to
thought and a self-referential
aspect that makes me very unhappy like i
see myself from outside is this horrible
just evil nasty thing and it's crippling
so so it's a shift in our perception a
little frame shift and the dose
tells you how far you shift um and the
kind tells you what you shift into so if
it's like lsd or
interesting thc that's my theory now
again how do i prove it
can't yeah yeah
what have we not touched on was there
something we're supposed to
there's a universe of things that we'll
just have to do a follow-up
yeah we definitely will i you know we
were gonna
medicine and all that that's a whole
nother conversation we talked about
a lot of things okay i have one question
i wrote okay someone said
i heard him talk on trigonometry
recently which i don't think is true
were you on trigonometry
perhaps they better no actually i wasn't
i saw that coming yeah i don't think so
perhaps they meant rebel wisdom okay
excellent he spoke of the problem of
changing
his opinion based on new information it
is old okay now see
we talked about grandstanding before i
think there's rational
it's almost like virtue signaling this
rational signaling i don't believe
people when they say i change my mind
based on new information
the reason why is that it's extremely
hard to change your mind
it's and not only that but would you
change your mind based on any new
information
are you saying that you have no other
value system embedded
so for example if the world told you
through some truth mechanism that you
should
kill your wife or kill your dog are you
telling me that you're going to override
your beliefs to follow what's rational
is rationality the god
why should you follow that if it leads
you to destruction
so i i saw that and i thought about
i don't believe people and i saw this
veritasium video once
not to pick on veritasium but veritasium
was in a
university crowd holding the camera to
himself and someone was saying
how is it that you change your mind when
you are presented with new beliefs
and he's like well you know these
beliefs you just
you get new information you update them
you just slot it in even though you
don't like
and i'm like you're so pretentious man
firstly you don't think like that
secondly it's not that easy thirdly
maybe you shouldn't because
well you don't know where rationality
alone will lead you rationality
is a it's like an arrow with no
direction
you have to direct it and that direction
process isn't exactly rational it's like
pre-rational
those were my thoughts and i wanted to
know what you thought about that dude
so how big of a jonathan height uh
understanding do you have not much not
much other than
big five and political belief that's it
right right right right right talk about
the big five um the moral palette you
know fairness versus
cheating authority versus subversion etc
so his other big
analogy which i think speaks exactly
what you're saying is this
so and i keep this here because i i i
want to be reminded of it
the elephant and the writer i'm
surprised not a monkey on the elephant
right that would be better it's just
someone one of my supporters sent me
this and so i use it as an example
so thank you uh patricia i think
sent me this so the elephant is our
primitive emotional
mind what daniel kahneman would call
system one
so it's it works on heuristics emotion
feeling intuition instant fast yes
it's the fast system exactly so it
happens
it's we share it with a lot of animals
it's it's um highly conservative
evolutionarily
ancient brain and it works to make these
snap judgments
it it holds our deepest sort of biases
and beliefs it's partially
genetic it's partially conditioned but
it is what it is
and it's the thing when i say oh we made
a decision you know six seconds before
we're aware of it
often that's our elephant just making
that decision unconsciously and feeding
it up
to this guy who is the writer
of the elephant that's our neocortex so
rational thought math moral reasoning
persuasion verbally uh those kind of
things
the the writer seems to be something
reasonably unique to higher mammals um
in that you know and probably
self-referential thought
occurs in that it's slower it's more
deliberate it takes more atp
to to make it happen and the theory was
oh we
we evolved the writer to control the
elephant so that
you know we are our rational thought
overrides emotion but look at the size
differential
like who's really in charge so height
argues that the data actually shows that
he's
reviewed that the l th the writer
is not the president in this little
consortium it's
the elephant's press secretary hmm
have you heard me go chris master in
a little bit and i saw that you'd
interviewed him that was the next thing
on my list to watch
so i'm sure he kind of talks about this
precisely right right
right same thing all these roads
converge because i think they're they're
pointing at some truth
and the idea is that it's a press
secretary because the elephant
emotionally beliefwise has already
decided
it then needs this writer to persuade
others in the tribe that we're right
because
our life depends on it hunting rights
breeding rights food rights in a tribe
so evolutionarily this writer evolved
as a persuasive tool well now you
weaponize that through social media
where everyone's got their elephant they
now have a like button
to say my elephant agrees and a comment
field to go here's what my writer thinks
of that
a dislike button to say or an angry
button to say my outfit disagrees and a
comment field to attack
and none of it goes to how do i change
my mind in the face of new data
right so when i say i've changed my mind
like for masks
elephant response on mass early on was
uh i'm a doctor
this is [ __ ] like having the public
wear a diaper on their face is dumb
it's not going to do anything because
people don't use it correctly they're
going to touch their face
at that time i thought this was also for
medically transmitted meaning
a lot on surfaces and been disproven so
i was telling people in videos listen i
think wearing a mask outside
as a public person unless it's an n95 or
a surgical grade mask
is a dumb idea and i don't want you
doing those things because you're going
to hurt my tribe which is the frontline
healthcare professionals
who don't have enough ppe and they're
seeing this right
and community spread isn't as high yet
well
when when that shifted for me was having
some guests on the show like monica
gandhi who said listen
even off-camera she was telling me
listen we don't have data that shows
that mass work that's a problem we don't
we have certain suggestions that it
reduces the inoculum of the virus
so that even a dumb diaper on your face
is going to reduce the sheer number of
viral
particles so you may then turn a icu
case
into a asymptomatic case because there's
some data to suggest that viral inoculum
especially in other diseases
matters for severity of illness and so
then i said okay this is different now
so now
anything on your face might reduce you
down to an asymptomatic case
and so then i said listen guys i think
probably i don't believe in math
mandates because my
libertarian elephant is like probably
not a good idea but
maybe we should say that this is not a
bad a bad thing and if it keeps us
bends the curve so that my colleagues in
the hospital can survive this and we do
okay then maybe that's a good thing
so that was an example of changing even
publicly what i was saying
the other thing that i changed and this
was pure bias in the beginning too
that i had to recognize i had a bias
like you said in the beginning towards
the authorities
like wait cdc is saying it's not a big
deal who's not calling this a pandemic
the chinese government scientists are
saying okay we like what they're doing
here they caught this early
so i did a video where it's like guys
this is what could happen i don't think
it is because the chinese have got this
under control it's the stupidest
it's still available i don't delete
videos it's out there in the beginning
of the family like january i'm like stop
freaking out
here's what's happening now this could
get bad these are the things we need to
worry about this way and they did a
great job
oh my god did that video not age well so
i leave those comments like
rip me a new one man i'm an idiot and
then i have to go back and say here's
why i change
now i'm very distrustful of anything
until i'm convinced by talking to enough
people that are i'm connected to or
reading the data that
that it's something different but it
still hurts it still hurts our belief
structure like if it violates like if
you told me tomorrow
man this vaccine that i've been talking
about publicly is harming people making
them infertile doing all this other
stuff here now we have data it's
incontrovertible or as close to
incontrovertible yes
i would i would want to die
like i it would feel so horrible because
my belief structure is
no actually i've looked at this data
i've used all my tools of belief
and science on it and i'm very convinced
this is safe
something crazy has happened okay the
first thing is to do is got to do a
video and say i was wrong about this
and that's going to hurt like it's going
to be the worst but
you have to you have to accept that
level of pain
and but i think you're right i think
it's very easy to virtue signal i
changed my mind
look at me i'm a better human and really
not be changing your mind at all
in fact if anything your fundamental
belief is i go wherever the popular
wisdom is or whatever will get me views
and you haven't changed that belief at
all so by changing this belief
you're just going with that flow and
that's something you have to be very
aware of it's it's tough it's re it's a
reason why i'm so
i'm not a great interviewee despite the
fact that we've been speaking for
quite some time because i don't have any
any staunch to beliefs
at least not that i'm conscious of as
soon as i put up a
proposition i can see its flaws and i
also
guide myself or try to by this i think
it's arthur kane who said
only the shallowest of mind can believe
that in
great controversy one side is mere folly
so when it comes to
anti-lockdown or anti-masks if there's a
large enough amount of people saying it
i want to hear what is your best
argument and perhaps you're not art
perhaps what you're saying
is false but the meaning behind it is
correct and you're not articulate enough
to put it forward so for example
i i find it strange that the i find it
extra
covet is such an anomaly man for many
reasons i find it strange
that it's the right that's anti-lockdown
when the left should be about liberties
and i also find it strange that
the left is for universally
pro-abortion and the right is
anti-abortion when
the it doesn't seem to map on exactly
and the reason why is
think of jainism jainism is about like
you mentioned
i don't even want to kill a cockroach i
bring that outside jainists
who are we would think of as the most
hippie like left-leaning people
are complete anti-abortion because it's
also life
and so then it's being is being
pro-abortion on the left
or is it that your team somehow decided
this through some other process and
you're identifying with the team
and that's why it's so it's such a
dangerous game to say i am left
or i am right what are the odds that the
35 tenants of the right and and the
45 of the left or whatever it may be are
ones that you align with you are you
it's it's a difficult game just to
attach yourself to
a team you man see this
okay you said you're not a good
interviewee
forget it but partially not a good
interviewer but no no no no so forget
about that what what my
my uh producer logan was telling me
before the show because he watched a
bunch of your stuff and he's like hey
don't interview kurt have a conversation
because he's tremendous he's just
absolutely tremendous asking these
questions and it'll
generate conversation i'm like that was
my plan because watching your stuff the
same thing
because you know what actually being a
good interviewee is boring as [ __ ]
because it means that again you have a
lot to say but not a lot of questions
not a lot of openness etc
sometimes i find i'm a better
interviewee than an interviewer because
i've been thinking about this stuff so
much that i want to just tell you all
about it and then
the idea is well where am i open to
these ideas now diving into something
you said
this this is the center piece of what i
call this alt middle thinking
in my tribe of people we have a lot of
conservatives a lot of libertarians a
lot of liberals
a couple marxists not a lot of very
far-right people but people that are
very
libertarian and they all we
we talk about it in terms of jonathan
heights like moral taste buds
so when you think about abortion etc by
the way remind me to tell you if we have
time about about
the video i did about abortion that boy
you can see how that triggers the
tribal behavior of in group out group
so long story short you have these taste
buds liberty versus oppression
that you value fairness versus cheating
loyalty versus betrayal
authority versus subversion care versus
harm so in other words
you know care versus self-explanatory
and the sixth one actually is um because
there's a little subtlety there
is sanctity versus degradation
this is from jonathan jonathan height in
his book the righteous mind he lays
these out why people just
good people disagree on politics and
religion and
what's interesting is each of these
issues
can be filtered through a moral pal your
moral palate that you're often born with
like you have these certain values
so liberty versus oppression so it turns
out liberals
tend to really emphasize they all have
all six but they emphasize
too which is fairness versus cheating
and care versus or you know or you know
yeah care versus harm so and that makes
sense because then you go okay they
don't like
rich people taking advantage of stuff
they want to take care of poor people
they you know these are the values they
project social justice etc
conservatives actually have those but
then they really value
loyalty versus betrayal look how the
republicans tend to be quite unified
even when trump does some crazy stuff
they're like yeah but he's our guy
right and then you have uh liberty
versus oppression well
yeah so it's a more libertarian value
and
sanctity versus degradation it turns out
liberals
and conservatives parse this quite
differently so a conservative will look
at sanctity versus degradation in terms
of religion versus
atheism or in terms of abortion the
sanctity of life
versus the despoilment of of that
through abortion
the liberal would take that same moral
palette and go sanctity of
my body my choice versus
you know some a state invading that
sanctity with a vaccine or with
me not allowing to do what i want with
my unborn fetus
so they can all kind of parse issues
through this now you then weaponize that
through
tribal behavior so the left has this
ideological checklist
what jordan peterson calls ideological
possession
so i just i don't even know how i feel
about some of these things but
my tribe votes this way and the right
has a similar
kind of set of doctrines so when you ask
the question i don't understand why the
right does this and then
some of that is ideological possession
some of that is they do tend to value
these
there's something in veteran something
yeah exactly
and then there was a oh so the abortion
piece that i did so i did
like one of those direct-to-camera
things it was when alabama's state
legislature was
you know intervening in abortion in some
way that a lot of physicians were saying
you know this is a bunch of
men can't legislate medicine this is a
medical procedure let doctors
do this do this um decision making with
with
patients so i did a video where i said
hey i agree with that like this is a
medical procedure this is
how it's done uh it should be the right
of of
uh women to make the choice with their
doctor and with whatever religious
belief they have etc it shouldn't be a
legislator doing this
in my opinion and this is the thing but
let me tell you a story about why i
understand
why people would be very opposed to
abortion on a deep moral level
when i was a fourth year medical student
or third year medical student i was
compelled to witness
second late second trimester abortions
at san francisco general hospital
and what i saw was you know fetus parts
being removed and this and that and i
i gave this very emotional story about
what it was like so
did that feel like murder to me at the
time absolutely could i understand why
people would feel this is a sanctity
versus degradation kind of violation
absolutely until we understand that
you're never going to have a dialogue
because you're going to think someone
else
is trying to oppress you it's a power
dynamic instead of a moral
dynamic we have different intermoral
intuitions about this let's talk about
it
and so i got a ton of messages from
people saying that's the most
cogent i've ever heard that's how i feel
as a doctor who performs abortions like
this and but then i got hate
from the a lot of abortion doctors and a
lot of very lefty lefters
who are like you're you're basically
normalizing violence against
abortion clinics by saying that by
giving anything
right right i know and i was like i
is i felt attract like attacked by this
tribe of healthcare professionals i was
like oh my god
but i i didn't remove it in fact i did
another video where i talked about it
more but
man it's rough right they want
they dislike the other side so intensely
that with your
nuance there's a part of your argument
that can be used
on the side that they dislike and so
they want to discount the argument
entirely
yeah yeah false equivalence again fears
its
ugly head man kurt are you pooped or
what bro
i'm looking forward to being that and
going to sleep
at some point and eating so let's wrap
it up
yeah yeah thank you so much man dude
this was uh
this was a real joy yeah yeah me too me
too i wasn't expecting to go on for more
than an hour and it's been two and
almost almost three
[Laughter]
i'm so sorry i know you're starving and
you're tired
please i want to hear please
tell your wife uh i'm deeply sorry and
that my wife hates me just as much
uh because i do the same thing um so at
least we have that
that kind of true equivalency so facing
what
that's going on overextended yeah yeah
okay uh come home you know we have plans
and i'm like but just
a couple more minutes i'm doing a show
or whatever it is so it is what it is
brother it's it's just a joy um
hopefully we can do this again at some
point in the future if you feel inclined
uh just let me know and and we'll make
it happen
we've never done a live format like this
oh great i'm i'm honored to be
the first oh man it's it's
really awesome to have you you're the
perfect guest for this not a guest it's
a conversation um
so thank you thank you and i and uh
we'll connect very soon um and to
everybody who's watching
uh thanks again to kurt check out his
stuff so
his uh podcast his show on youtube is
called theories of everything i've put
links in
his documentary is called better left
unsaid and
it's a ride it is a right is the
director's cut available publicly
on betterleftonsetfilm.com exclusively
so
if you get it from itunes or google or
voodoo
firstly much of the money or some of the
money goes toward them whereas
from the website most if not all the
money go toward the filmmakers there's
some split between
different places but also on the website
get access to the director's code i
believe for
free if you just buy the regular version
and you don't get access to the
directors club find my email it's online
somewhere and email me and i'll send you
the link
just send me that's awesome and you
funded this thing with kickstarter
indiegogo stuff type
that's your thing yeah that's great and
it's personal money
it's really well done you guys so if you
want to dive into like
the craziness that's going on in society
in a way that's so unique
uh watch the director's cut really
watch the director's cut if you're into
this because it is it goes really deep
it's
it's brilliant so thank you so much guys
and until
next time i'm going to figure out how to
stop this kurt you can sign off you are
the bomb i also wanted to make a quick
amendment it's when i said personal
money my brother invested
heavily into the film so i just want to
make sure that that said i don't want to
misrepresent
so thank you family family and you are
identical
as far as i'm concerned that's how i see
it so yeah thanks for making the
clarification but that's awesome
it's really wonderful to have support
right there's a deep gratitude that
arises from that um like my supporters
on
facebook and stuff that pay for all this
equipment on youtube
they're the best they got some great
equipment okay man
i gotta get going thank you i'll sign
off and you can speak to the audience if
you like
i'll wrap it up kurt thank you um guys
for the recording is it all right if i
just talk to you quickly about that
you'll send me it to dropbox i will send
you a dropbox version of this very long
file that we'll export over the next
two hours and then i'll send you a link
and then you can put it together however
you like
great thank you i love it brother thanks
have a great one man
it's been a pleasure i appreciate it
thank you man likewise
guys that was intense
how we've been talking for almost three
hours that's crazy
um wow so
you know we started out kind of slow and
got in the groove
as uh he's been really sleep deprived
and doing podcast after podcast
let's take a few comments right now just
because i want to wrap up with your
voice because i think that's important
and we didn't get enough of that in the
thing because we were so into our
ourselves
thank you ann for your support on
youtube and andrew dunbar
um actually andrew dunbar says the
sanctity versus degradation dichotomy
also applies to how
some on the right view gun rights
totally true
sanctity versus degradation and gun
rights liberty versus oppression and gun
rights
i you know if you don't understand how
someone who holds opposing views
sees the world morally you don't
understand
them at all and you're going to vilify
them because you're going to see them
through your own moral matrix
which is not how they see the world and
you need to understand that our moral
matrix
allows us to do what we perceive is good
in the world
we filter it through that so everybody
most people
are trying to be good which is why you
can assume good intent
it used to be i would get very triggered
by people with different political views
and i would assume that they were just
bad
because i was using my moral matrix my
moral taste buds as the
as the litmus test or the filter
now i get excited to hear opposing views
because i want to know
what the moral matrix is it's coming
from and honor it you go oh god you're
trying to be good and this is how you
see being good okay i can't be mad at
you
i disagree for these reasons but let's
have a conversation what do we agree on
morally what do we agree on we want to
see in the world right and then you can
start from a consensus
sort of common human common humanity
politics instead of this identity where
we're all separate fighting each other
as tribes
that's really what a lot of identity
politics that used to be a great thing
in the civil rights movement has
devolved into this
our group existential battle against
everybody else that's a power struggle
trying to
oppress us well what if we just assume
good intent and try our best instead of
vilifying other people because of the
way they're born right
born white or born asian or born
whatever like forget that dude that
that's horseshit that's
that's the definition of discrimination
um
june black says i felt so bad for him
being so tired at the beginning
glad he came around yeah dude i i really
hang on a second i just
ah there we go i'm still recording
that's good um
i felt really bad for him and i felt
like
what you know we were scheduled to do
this and i was like am i torturing this
guy because
you know we didn't even know what we
were going to talk about we had no
agenda you know we connected via email
and
and uh i was worried that it was just
going to go off the rails real fast and
uh it didn't it went on the rails which
was off the rails
so it was a lot of fun for me yeah it
was intense right janna
um george shepherd my fulcrum is
different
uh from so-and-so's fulcrum that's a
good way to look at it
like right where's your fulcrum that's
great
ashley stewart i feel the exact same way
i never learn from people who think
exactly like i do you can't
it's just a kind of group thing um jamie
vance
how do you break through to people who
allow their moral compass to dictate a
conversation i struggle greatly
with helping people uh see that
everything is true but partial
so that idea of alt middle that
everything's true but partial
is a kind of moral assertion it's a kind
of meta belief about belief
so i think i think
accepting that person as they are is one
thing this is how they're showing up
it's the best they can do at this point
and then gently this is very hard gently
nudging
through conversation some ideas that
might open them up a little too
first of all maximizing whatever level
they're at in terms of their thinking
and then opening them to whatever that
adjacent level is and it i see it happen
again and again
i see it it's not impossible it's not
that we change our minds it's that our
minds grow
they they transcend and include what
came
before to use ken wilbur's language um
you know it's a beautiful thing um
oh how kind of you theories of
everything kurt jeiman gaul commented
thank you zubin can't hear you but
typing to say thank you kurt you're the
best man
what's kurt's full name kurt jaimungal
and it's in the description for the
video dorothy morrison afterwards you
can see it there
um j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
he's a he's awesome really like i love
people who think like that
and who are self-reflective and very
very intellectual but able to
also relax into a kind of
beyond intellectualism it's really key
um sophia says uh on youtube says the
ego has a lot of power
always reasserting uh through and into
survival mechanisms so
sophie let's think about ego for a
second i don't know why i'm still
talking about talking for three hours
and i gotta be somewhere but i'm into
this now
it's a kind of a flow state oh my neck's
going to hurt tomorrow
um
we tend so in spiritual circles in
particular in meditation circles and
those kind of circles that look at this
stuff
the ego tends to be objectified as
something that's there it's like this
entity that
we need to fight or we need to overcome
or that's doing these bad things to us
or so on
and i think when you approach it from
that angle
i'm not saying you're doing this i'm
just saying i'm speaking just expositing
on this
when we approach ego from that angle we
turn it into an object what's
the only thing that can turn other
things into objects
ego so my friend angelo says when you go
to war with the ego
it's the ego going to war with itself
it it's a very subtle it's a
pattern of conditioned thoughts beliefs
and perceptual distortions
that are just happening just like
everything else is just happening
it's just happening and what happens is
it binds attention
so that we think this is it and the ego
knows us better than we know ourselves
it's had millions of years to evolve
with us
it knows our deepest darkest thoughts
and knows how to manipulate us now
again i'm objectifying it but let's just
say that pattern of energy
is really good at tricking attention
into following thoughts about
self and so on creating the sense of
self
this person behind my eyes that's seeing
objects around me as separate
instead of just everything as one thing
one as
as um kirk called it one vellum
one substrata one thing
one reality and the oh by the way jody
jacobs on facebook says i stayed the
full
three hours because i love this
conversation thank you both
jody that makes me so oh
i just love that i love that that really
warms me up my ego
but even beyond ego there's something
like
there's something in our authentic bits
right
that when you connect with another
person
like we connected during this
conversation you and i and kurt and all
that
it's just this sense of just elevation
like oh
that's beautiful that's humanity at its
most connected right
even if we don't agree on everything um
yeah jose check out his movie so his
movie's crazy it's like real
experimental and weird and
it doesn't seem like it's all going to
come together and then at the end it's
kind of like
what so you got you got to check it out
it's some crazy [ __ ]
um all right now i probably i probably
should go because i can hear this
box trying to record and it's probably
running out of space hold on
yeah it's crazy it's still actually
recording i don't know i didn't know it
had that much space
on that card um cogito ergo
ego that's right george shepherd i think
therefore i am ego
ego itself is a friend it can be a it's
a it's a
it's a pattern of energy that's kept us
alive that's goal is to protect us from
a
seeming external world to it understands
that we're separate
and it says okay as a separate thing
this is how we stay safe it doesn't know
better it can't know better it's not a
thing
this pattern of energy we should honor
it we should thank it
we should be grateful for it but we
should recognize it for what it is we
should recognize when it's trying to
co-opt
and turn everything into a story
you know the story of the one who woke
up
the story of the one who meditates the
story of the one who's embarking on a
spiritual journey whatever it is
so anyways
june black it was three hours didn't
seem like it man i can't believe you
guys are with
with us this long ashley same thing you
guys are crazy
i do need to hydrate sandra thank you
i'm tired um
samantha man you guys are great i you
guys are the core audience because there
was like
you know about a hundred and some on
each platform the whole time you guys
are really the core
hardcore devotees and i i'm so grateful
for you
all right i gotta stop doing this it's
an affectation but i love it when i went
to thailand when i was younger
this was it was a very buddhist society
and everybody would just do this and i
got in the habit of that
and it's a kind of a i see you as me
and a gratitude thing at the same time
it's really lovely
all right i'd rather do it than shake
hands honestly
um all right i love you guys now i got
to figure out how to end this
i'm going to say bye to youtube first so
bye bye youtube
till next time
and then i got to figure out
facebook i think the way i'll do that is
i'll fade to black and then i'll end
when it ends all right guys
you